à Tôi vẫn nhớ cái video lần trước là tâm
sự cuối năm chuyển sang tâm sự đầu năm
Long
nè
Ừ chào bạn Uầy có vài bạn đã on rồi Tôi
đang nghĩ tôi phải sẽ phải thông báo ở
đâu đấy không kiểu mình sẽ thành tự kỷ
phết Ờ anh dùng max gì vậy Tôi dùng
Macbook
M1 16 GB
à Nhân tiện cũng khoe luôn
tôi hôm hôm qua hôm qua vừa đi mua C
thinh bass các bạn biết thinh bass không
ạ Có nên có nên gi chia sẻ luôn không
nhỉ chia sẻ nó giống quảng cáo á nhưng
đại khái Ừ tôi cho mấy ông xem được này
Ờ đầu tiên
thì đầu tiên thì cho đây Hàn chity 4 cho
mấy ông biết thì th bass M1 có quạt
không á Macbook e thực ra không có quạt
mạnh đâu nhưng mà nói chung là không nên
nó tôi thấy chạy Ví dụ ở điển hình đấy
Tôi vừa mới mua th bass đúng không Uầy
kiểu quay lại Windows ấy
thấy thấy đúng kiểu dạng là máy Windows
nóng vãi chưởng đặc biệt với ting bass
nữa th bass bản chất nó là dòng đây
ting bass là dòng laptop thế nào chẳng
hạn đây cho mấy ông có thêm góc nhìn nhá
hỏi ch
đấy
Ờ cái dòng này dành cho danh doanh nhân
thường là thế bởi vì nó khá là mỏng nhẹ
và kiểu nhưng mà nhưng mà nó vẫn kiểu
đây bền bỉ này hiệu suất cao này các thứ
các thứ có thể nói chung là phù hợp cho
anh em ờ hay di chuyển nhiều để mà nói
thực ra không phải dành cho anh em lập
trình mình lắm đâu gọi là nó cũng có cái
sự kiểu bền với kiểu hiệu suất cũng phải
cao nhưng mà công nhận là máy nó vẫn
nóng đấy đấy còn Macbook thì công nhận
máy má các thứ các thứ e m m2 Tôi không
biết nhưng mà chuẩn là E thì theo như
tôi nhớ thì e nó làm tại sao nó lại mỏng
nhẹ hơn so pro nó cố để phục vụ kiểu
dạng là nó sẽ tối giản đi Điển thành cái
quạt của ông để cho nó mỏng nhẹ mà pin
nó vẫn không bị pin nó vẫn trâu
đấy Nên là dùng lâu thì đúng là vẫn sẽ
nóng tí
một tí thôi không thể bằng tôi cầm con
ting quay lại kiểu Dùng Windows máy nóng
vãi chưởng chưa nói về hiệu suất nhá Bởi
vì mình chư tôi tôi hôm qua tôi thử cài
cài đầu tiên thì mua máy người ta vẫn
luôn cài sẵn đúng không ạ nhưng mà tôi
vẫn thử muốn cài lại Win Nói chung là
một phần cũng sợ bảo mật các thứ sợ
người ta cài sẵn cái gì gì đó Và trong
máy nên là tôi cũng về tôi cà lại Win
tôi lên trang của anh anh
DV trên này để tải phiên bản Win xong
rồi tôi thấy trong này có sẵn r food r
food đây r food là cái phần mềm để mà
kiểu biến cái USB của ông có thể là cài
được Kiểu bot được để cài Win ng là ông
sẽ tải cái này về có file ISO ấy xong
ông dùng rf để ông kiểu nạp cái đấy vào
trong usb x cài lại và có vẻ tôi cài bị
l lỗ hay gì gì đó Thế nó thiếu driver
rồi đủ kiểu luôn đấy nên là thôi lại
phải vứt ra hàng để nhờ người ta
ex Windows nữ là cài sẵn cho bộ Office
luôn
đấy Máy mới về nên là cũng
chưa Máy mới về nên cũng chưa kiểu dạng
cài thêm các thứ thì tí tôi sẽ tự vọc
vạch nhưng mà ý tôi là như thế nghĩa là
ờ lúc mà mình dùng m ấy mình có một cái
gì đó kiểu đúng kiểu đây tôi định tâm sự
về cái vụ này Thực ra tôi định tâm sự
hết toàn bộ những cái trên trước bởi vì
cái này để lâu quá sự quên hết ý nhưng
mà thôi để dưới Ưu nhược khi dùng Win ý
thì thì rõ ràng là win khiến cho để hình
con người như tôi một người rất thích
vọc vạch các thứ các thứ tìm tòi thậm
chí là phải sửa lỗi khi gặp vấn đề như
thế hôm qua một cả tối ngồi Tìm các thứ
thứ còn mắ Thì bởi vì Nói chung đồ của
Apple ấy nó gọi là tính ra nó vẫn là dễ
dùng đúng không nên Thành A nó Nó kiểu
bị smort qu K smartphone hay Smart gì đó
thành ra là kiểu Tôi thường gọi khái
niệm đấy Gọi smartphone nhưng mà d d
user ấy người dùng mấy cái đấy Nó kiểu
do nó quá dễ dùng quá tiện thành ra là
người dùng không không thèm tìm hiểu
không Vào phần cài đặt để tìm hiểu vì
vừa mua về có thể dùng được luôn thành
ra là kiểu nó làm người dùng nó bị kiểu
dạng nhỉ ỷ lại xong rồi dần dần nó sẽ
thành lười rồi Vân Vân Vân ngại động vào
vân vân khiến cho mình kiểu kém đi đúng
không ạ Ơ thumbnail để cuối năm à lỗi
tôi tí n sửa lại nào tôi cũng định phải
sửa lại hết th nail để cuố nằm à th bây
giờ vẫn kịp th C đổi một cái slime mà
hình như cái này vậy đúng nhỉ À đâu đâ
làm
cái
sẽ có đầu năm ch mấy ông đơn giản mà
đúng đơn giản Xong
rồi Ờ
tí tôi trả lời bình luận Á
à Chục shop năm mới các thứ Thực ra thì
tôi từng nói về mấy ông về cái điều trúc
rồi Ờ nó tôi thực ra là gần đây tôi mới
phải kiểu quen dần với Vic Chúc người
khác thứ Thực ra là chuẩn là tôi có quan
điểm Chúc đó là Ừ đôi khi mình thường
hay Chúc những cái thứ mà mình muốn thực
ra người khác không cần giống như kiểu
Tôi chúc mấy ông có yêu ấy Nhưng mà chắc
gì mấy ông cần việc đấy chắc gì mấy ông
muốn điều đấy mấy ông muốn độc thân thì
sao Thấy kiểu
thế nên là tôi rất hạn chế việc chúc
thường là cố máo và tôi sẽ chúc mọi
người vạn sự như ý nĩ Tùy bạn K thẻo như
bạn được hoặc là chúc sức khỏe chắc là
tôi sẽ chúc mấy ông về sức khỏe thôi
Chúc mấy ông có sức khỏe và tôi cũng thế
tôi sẽ tự chúc tôi có sức khỏe thì anh
em còn ngồi stream đều
được nhưng mà nhắc với việc stream đều
thì tôi đang có một tí cân nhắc tí cái
này
À tôi trước mắt thì tôi sẽ nói qua cái
này rõ ràng là có rất nhiều cái ở đây
tôi điền nhưng mà chắc là tôi sẽ ưu tiên
nói này trước bởi vì tiện đang nhắc vụ
stream kiểu livestream như này thì có
thể có thể sắp tới có thể lịch sẽ thay
đổi à
không à Cũng có thể đấy cũng thể Đấy tức
là sao Ờ chuẩn hôm trước tôi có nói mấy
ông về cái vụ là tôi định học gì rồi
đúng không
âm luyện âm này học ở bên anh Huy eql
này anh sang thì thực ra cả về code cả
eql này Đấy s các thứ thứ này đúng không
ạ để chuẩn bị à để chuẩn bị cho chắc học
xong đúng này cho rồi Tôi nghĩ phải sáng
năm ấy thì nghĩa là sau đó thì tôi mới
tự tin đi dậy được đúng không ạ Thì hôm
vừa rồi hôm vừa
rồi tôi Kiểu lâu lắm rồi không đầu tiên
là tôi vẫn trúc tết thầy tôi thầy người
thầy mà dạy tôi lập trình kiểu kiểu dạy
tôi để tôi bước chân vào con đường lập
trình này và kiểu thầy cũng là người
định hướng tôi rất rất nhiều khi để từ
việc là đi mời tôi ở lại đi dậy xong rồi
Kiểu à Chỉ tôi rất nhiều cái rất rất
nhiều nhưng mà cái hồi mà đi dậy nữa ấy
thầy còn bảo tôi làm phần mềm nữa để mà
không kiểu Hồi đấy thì cũng bị áp lực
các thứ khi mà kiểu vừa dậy cả ngày rồi
thầy vẫn bắt Ngồi làm phần mềm các thứ
nhưng hóa ra thì kiểu về sau mới biết
được là khi mà đi dậy thì ông kiểu bị à
Kiểu ông không Ông Không động vào code
mấy ông sẽ thực hành mấy mà chủ yếu Toàn
là mấy cái kiến thức cơ bản cũng biết
rồi ấ không sẽ bị may một kiến thức đi
vân vân đấy thầy vẫn bắt tôi tự tìm Tò
ngồi làm phần mềm các thứ thì cải thiện
trình độ lên đấy nên là thầy Tôi thường
ai nói thầy dân chuyên toán nên thầy có
tầm nhìn thầy giỏi lắm
à Nên là buổi Vừa rồi tôi mới mời thầy
kiểu xin thầy một buổi đi cà phê để ngồi
kiểu Lâu không nói chuyện lại với thầy x
rồi ngồi à Hỏi hỏi đáp nhiều thắc mắc
các thứ kiểu chuyện tương lai chuyện
kiểu cả sự nghiệp lẫn cả chuyện tình cảm
chẳng hạn đấy x Cuối cùng thì hôm đấy là
hôm thầy MC tiếng bảo dù thầy đi cà phê
thầy đồng ý sau cuối cùng hôm đấy tôi
lại vào trường BCH khoa
apptech để tham gia buổi khai xuân ở bên
đấy vì kiểu hóa ra thầy bây giờ về làm ở
bên đấy
gài một cách vô tình gài không biết được
khiến tôi tự nhiên tôi phải kiểu tham
gia cái buổi hôm đấy xong còn lên chục
ảnh cùng mọi người như thật còn nhận lì
xì cùng mọi người ạ vãi chưởng mọi người
thì cứ ra bắt tay kiểu Ơ Long về đây dậy
à các thứ bởi vì có một vài người quen
cũ của tôi các thứ đấy rồi điển hình
nhất là à à đặc biệt nhất là có một bạn
bạn nữ bạn bạn đấy á Đang mang thai đang
có vẻ là cũng
ờ ừ bạn ấy cũng có nói là anh về dạy
thay em à Vì em sắp nghỉ đẻ rồi đấy vậy
chưởng Hồi cuối cùng thì đùng một phát
thế Đang từ kiểu kế hoạch sang năm đấy
đấy gì gì đó thì sang tuần là tôi đã
phải đi dậy rồi Tôi đang không biết mai
sẽ nói chuyện với sếp như thế nào để xin
việc nghỉ đi
thay vì đi làm thì mình sẽ đi dậy à
không phải nhầm nhầm nhầm nghĩa là mình
sẽ nghỉ một buổi hàng tuần để đi dậy
nó nó cứ nó chính thức như thế thường
chính thức như thế thì sẽ
chuyện được với
sếp Còn nếu mà nói chuyện được với sếp
thì đùng một phát thứ tư tuần sau tôi
sẽ dạy ở trong chính đại học Bách Khoa
bên Bách Khoa Aptech đã liên kết được
với bên đại học Bách Khoa để dạy được
đầu tiên là có trụ kiểu trụ sở trụ sở
hay chi nhánh à Hay gì gì đó Nói chung
là có thể dạy ở ở trong trong trường
Bách Khoa và nó còn có bằng đại học Bách
Khoa
đó kiểu đùng phát kiểu khá nhiều cái
bươc ngoặt và biến đổi từ đầu năm đến
giờ đối với tôi hãy chưởng
nhiều như tôi cảm thấy cũng may mà mình
vừa vừa kịp mua con laptop các thứ thứ
nói chung là tôi vẫn ở bệnh ở Hà Nội mà
anh em có cơ hội gì anh em đi cà phê
giao lưu thôi cà phê giao lưu liên tục
luôn tuần này kiến lịch luôn Không biết
tuần sao nào Tuần này kiến lịch rồi ông
nào tôi cũng rủ đi cà phê có ông sợ sợ
tôi ạ chẳng nhều lúc đầu chủ động kiểu
chủ động với mình thấy mình nhiệt tình
chủ động lại sợ
Không Biết Sợ gì Sợ kiểu cha là tưởng đa
cấp hay gì
ông anh em làm buổi cà phê giao lưu được
nhiều đúng à đây đ nói giờ thinh bass
thì đây các thứ bàn phím có vẻ chất
lượng gõ các thứ thứ Thực ra là tôi cũng
không gõ nhiều Ừ chắc là có Nhưng mà
thực ba chuẩn là tôi mua bàn phím có thể
mang đi và và chuột thể mang đi n Tôi
thấy hơi bị kiểu tự nhiên gần đây Hơi bị
lười mang ấy đi checkpoint hôm qua tôi
thử dùng cái ch check check checking mà
đúng không check po checkpoint này nó
chck po à phát âm N
checkpoint checkpoint nó đ nào giờ
checkpoint kiểu thế Ờ
thôi thử dùng cái này bởi vì hôm qua cài
cài lại bị lỗi driver nỗi không Cái cái
Touch cái Touch cái vùng
Touch gọi là gì nhỉ Không phải Touch ID
Nó là cái gì vùng kiểu dùng được chuột
ấy Ừ Cái CH này là cái núm màu đỏ cái
vùng chuột ở dưới nó là cái gì nhỉ Cái
Touch gì nhỉ Touch B đúng không t b Ờ
thì hôm qua hôm qua cài kiểu gì cái đấy
nó cũng chết luôn á em phải dùng thử cái
này cảm thấy không hể quen Cái
này CH chọn cấu hình đ đấy thì nếu tôi
là dân công nghệ
à Dân lập trình đi lập trình và di
chuyển à Thử ra không cần vài di chuyển
nhiều thp thôi à thì nên dùng dòng máy
thp nào và nó và nó tôi nhớ ở lần cuối
hỏi nó Nó đề xuất cho tôi cái x1 và và
tôi đã mua nó hôm qua công nhận là cũng
bà anh Anh kiếm cho em con đây X series
này X1 carbon này
này
trọng lượng nhẹ hiệu suất tốt
từng dùng con d Seon nó nặng vãi trưc
nên là nên là cũng cần nhắc à gì nhỉ ờ
thì đang nói sở gì Ừ Nói chung là hôm
qua Đúng kiểu người có một tí tiền hơn
rồi nên thành ra là hôm qua cũng mạnh
mồm kiểu anh cứ lấy cho em con con nào
kiểu đắt đắt tí đi kiểu Tại sao anh lại
cho em con này nghĩa là nghĩa là lúc đầu
ng
ta kiểu bên đấy cũng chắc là bởi vì the
test này kiểu nhiều người mua máy nên
thành ra là kiểu cũng thiếu xong rồi Họ
đưa cho tôi con 30 30 củ
à chip p dòng chip P là chip kiểu hiệu
năng ấy chứ lúc đầu C Người ta còn đưa
tôi con chip u chip u là tiết kiệm năng
lượng thì nó kiểu dạng Tôi không thích à
và gì nh Ờ con đấy thì nó lại có màn
hình cảm ứng đấy Tôi không thích cái màn
hình cảm ứng lắm Bởi vì thì theo quan
điểm đơn giản Thứ nhất là tôi đang muốn
là con máy dòng khá kiểu mạnh lúc đầu
tôi Kiểu cái ngân sách của tôi sẽ tầm 30
đến 40 mà Thì tôi đang kiếm là kiểu mắc
cấu hình tầm 40 họ lại không có 40 Họ
đưa tôi con 30 đã là kiểu thấp nhất tiêu
chuẩn rồi sau rồi Đã thế bây giờ còn màn
hình cảm ứng thì tôi cứ tư duy kiểu đơn
giản nó là
màn hình cảm ứng thì chắc chắn là nó sẽ
phải bỏ ít nhất là ít nhất là 1 2 triệu
cho cái màn hình nên là thành ra là cái
tiền cho cấu hình đấy nó còn yếu hơn
đúng không ạ quan điểm như thế đúng
không ạ Thế Thành ra tôi cũng từ chối
tôi bảo em bâ kiếm em còn đắt tiền hơn
đấy và và màn hình cảm ứng thì né được
thì tốt các thứ bởi vì em Thứ nhất là
không nhu cầu Nếu mà kiểu mình không nhu
cầu mình đương nhiên là người ta bảo
mình có thể tắt đi nhưng mà rõ ràng tôi
bảo rồi tự nhiên kiểu ông sẽ gần như ông
sẽ bỏ ra 1 2 triệu gì đó chỉ cho cái
tính năng đấy mà tính năng đấy không
dùng thay vì tiền đấy đắp hết vào chip
hay là cái gì gì đó khác đấy Thy công
nhận hôm hôm qua là một trong những cái
dấu ấn để đời khi có thể nổ kiểu Anh ơ
cho em có đắt hơn C th thử xu Cuối cùng
thì họ vẫn có được một con à con chip y
à gen m 11
i7 32 KB khá là ổn thức ra là s SD chỉ
là 512 Tôi định nâng lên nhưng mà tôi
cũng cân nhắc kiểu bởi vì kiểu cũng muộn
rồi không kiểu muốn lấy máy về nhanh nên
là không bảo người ta kiểu thay ổ Chắc
về sau nếu mà có nhu cầu thì sẽ thay ổ
tôi định mua con này sẽ là sẽ là dùng
đầu tiên là dùng Win đã để mà phục vụ
diệc dậy các thứ nhưng mà về sau code ấy
Thực ra vẫn có thể code trên win giống
như hố trước đã làm thôi Nhưng tôi đang
nghĩ về sau chuẩn thì có thể sẽ cài song
song thêm cả Linux à để mà Linux U2 để
mà mình sẽ thử code trên đấy lại thêm
trải nghiệm lúc đấy Ui Nếu thế Mình dụng
không phải song song nữa dùng ba hệ điều
hành cng lúc về tôi vẫn có máy MC ở trên
công
Ôi tôi nói liên tục như cái máy luôn ạ
định
không ạ
Ờ J team thì về cơ bản là không cho dù
mấy anh đấy Đều hacker hack hủng các thứ
nhưng mà anh ấy thường mấy anh ấy tôi
thấy là thường là ít khi chia sẻ về hack
lắm kiểu cốm lắm ở Việt Hảo chứ Nói
chung là không không chia sẻ gì nhiều
mấy tôi thấy là có cái kênh là gì nh Ờ
gì nh tự nhiên quên mất tên
rồi Cooky hân hoan Đúng rồi mấy ông tra
cái p đấy là một trong p Tôi cảm thấy
khá là truyền cảm hứng về việc an ninh
mạng bảo mật các thứ các thứ khá là hay
đọc mấy bài cuốn
có sao không anh dòng m thì lập trình
Tôi nghĩ là lập trình di động động có vẻ
ngon chứ nếu mà giả sử iOS không biết
Android thế nào nhưng mà tôi từng nghe
việc là Android cũng vô
Win code là để mà có thể kiểu sâu màn
hình lên cho sinh viên rồi các thứ thứ
Nên là nên là tôi mới phải mua chứ không
thì tôi dùng máy m Cũng được tôi lúc hồi
trước tôi định là mua hẳn Macbook Pro
các th thứ mà chứ chứ không phải là kiểu
mình mua chưa
kiểu gì được free ạ bản chất là không có
gì kiểu gì đâu thường là nó sẽ hết hạn
mình thường haay đương nhiên phải crack
nghĩa là mình phải dùng cái phần mềm nào
đó crack nó đi nhưng mà đương nhiên là
phải Tìm những phần mềm ở mấy cái trang
uy tín không thì lại cài virus vào máy
để bạn thì
bây giờ cần học Mobile để làm Đán the
học flotter hay react native ạ Ờ cái này
em hỏi các bạn ở trong discord nhá Anh
cũng chưa động ở cả hai không biết trả
lời thế nào thật
không à
Ờ anh nghĩ là để trả lời mấy câu có nên
hay không thì thứ nhất là trong đầu mình
đã muốn rồi thì mình cứ thử đã nhưng mà
thử ở đây là thử là làm thật chứ không
phải thử theo kiểu là làm vui vui các
bạn Tôi đang nghĩ là hôm trước hôm trước
tôi nghĩ một cái đó là các bạn khi muốn
thử một cái gì đó để biết được chắc chắn
là nó phù hợp với mình hay không ấy Các
bạn nên thử nó trong một khoảng thời
gian đấy là một cái thước đo gì cũng
tương đối ví dụ là bạn thử nó trong vòng
3 tháng để bạn cảm thấy là có thích nó
không có thấy nó phù hợp hay không các
thứ rồi đánh giá tiếp chứ không phải nói
mồm bất kỳ ai khuyên các bạn được vì
chính các bạn mới là người biết được nó
phù hợp Vy không
đấy em b ra Script nhưng vào công ty
công ty lại đẩy qua làm Java em phải vừa
làm vừa tìm hiểu lội trình th nào hơi bị
loạn kiến thức
Ờ Thực ra là ngôn ngữ lập trình đâu quan
trọng đâu nếu mà bạn đã là lập trình
viên chuẩn thì bạn học ngôn ngữ mỗi ngôn
ngữ nó sẽ đương nhiên nó sẽ có khác khác
một tí như lại càng cho mình thêm tư duy
ở lập trình viên nên là thời gian đầu ai
cũng bị loạn thôi kể cả con nhà người ta
luôn con nhà người ta tôi cũng từng gặp
rồi họ cũng loạn như bình thường chẳng
qua là họ bớt loạn nhanh hơn mình mình
gọi là mình mình loạn Nhưng mà mình kiểu
mất hơi nhiều thời gian để làm quen thì
thời gian đầu tôi cũng thế thì mình cứ
phải mình hạn chế chế ngồi đọc tài liệu
Thôi mình cứ phải làm thực chiến đã đấy
là quan điểm của tôi về tôi quen việc
học theo kiểu thực hành hơn là lý thuyết
nên thành ra là tôi cứ phải thực hành
một vài cái tôi sẽ tự vỡ lẽ ra
qua FPT academy à bên FA để mà dạy nhưng
mà Thứ nhất là tôi trao đổi bên đấy lần
cuối Trao đổi là đầu năm ngoái đầu năm
ngoái đúng nhở ui Không biết bao lâu ấ
kiểu mới sang năm chẳng biết được năm
ngoái năm kia nữa nhưng mà đại khái Thì
lần cuối Trao đổi cũng cách đây hơn một
năm khá là lâu rồi là bên đấy lại không
muốn dạy pp Bởi vì bên đấy thực ra không
muốn dạy p bởi vì cái đầu da của họ luôn
muốn cam kết cái đầu da sinh viên mà tất
cả thường hay làm bên một là bên FPT
luôn hay là đối tác FPT thì bên đối tác
cả hai thì đều không không không cần pp
lắm thế thành ra là họ không dạy pp Họ
dạy được Kiểu Java hoặc là mấy ngôn ngữ
khác kiểu csap hay.net để sinh viên có
thể thực chiến được luôn thành ra là
kiểu khi mà tôi chuyên p Tôi muốn sang
đấy tôi đám phán thì nó gọi nhở họ có vẻ
Đang chưa tin tưởng lắm Thực ra tôi cũng
có thuyết phục họ rồi là cứ để em làm
rồi nó thế mạnh của em chứ bây giờ bảo
em dạy ngôn ngữ khác thì làm sao mà em
dạy được đúng không Bởi vì dạy đi dậy là
mình phải rất là chắc chắn về nó và phải
có kinh nghiệm thực tế về nó nữa thì mới
ổn đúng không ạ nên là nói chung là tôi
tôi nhận lời về bên B Khoa uptech này
dậy không phải là tôi sẽ dạy ở đấy lâu
dài tôi không ý định thế Nói chung là
bởi vì đấy giống vừa nãy nói là kiểu có
một bạn sắp phải nghỉ để nên là đúng là
tôi cứ cảm thấy là cần thật gấp thật tôi
nếu có thể tôi sẽ sang đấy hỗ trợ cho
đến hết cái khóa này chắc là 34 hàng nữa
bên đấy cũng sang bên đấy dạy bây giờ
khá là tương đối dễ với tôi Vì dạy p cơ
bản với larel thì quá quá giành rồi đúng
không nên là chắc là không sao
còn còn việc là sẽ dậy đấy lâu dài Tôi
không hứa gì cả tôi vẫn muốn nói chuyện
bên FPT các thứ nữa vì tính ra bên đấy
đã liên hệ với tôi trước Lâu rồi mình
không Mình không thể kiểu cứ thế mà tìm
mối ngon hơn thì cho mình bỏ qua được
Anh chỉ có tiếng Nhật sau này xin việc
làm ở Việt Nam tại Việt Nam được không ạ
Được chứ em bây giờ kiểu rất nhiều nơi
thấy Nhật tuyển bên mình nhiều mà Tôi
thấy một đống công ty giờ tuyển tiếng
nhật luôn không tuyển tiếng Anh đâu nói
chung là em có thêm một cái kiểu một cái
ngoại ngữ nữa thì là tạo thành cơ hội
Mình rất nhiều
cũng rất là thích bản chất là tôi thích
Dell hơn so Lúc mà tôi biết vụ thp này
là lenov tôi không có ấn tượng lắm Về
cái hãng này nh cho dù nhiều anh em
khuyên thp Nhưng mà tôi kiểu không ấn
tượng lắm Về cái hã này bằng D cho đến
khi tôi biết D nó nó có mỗi hai cổng đều
x x bé đi mỗi hai cổng tha xi giống hết
cái con m bây giờ đang dùng thì tôi lập
tức là thôi dẹp bởi vì cái con thp kia
Ít ra nó có đầy đủ Cẩm HDMI hay USB các
thứ đủ kiểu để mà tôi mang di chuyển th
Tôi không phải cầm theo một cái kiểu Hub
một cái gì đó nữa để mà kiểu nối vào
đúng không
là là nó cũng giống bên thp thôi Tôi
nghĩ tản biệt yếu bằng nhau Anh đang
dùng Macbook ha Mac mini ạ Macbook e đây
đây có bạn trả lời trường em dạy Mobile
mú 1 khóa r cho tự học và ch không biết
trả lời Mấy cái câu liên quan đến các
trường hay là học phí như nào nhảy cảm
lắm tôi thể kiểu mấy ông mà cứ nhắc mấy
cái nh cảm quan cắt thừ tôi tôi tôi vừa
thấy một kiểu danh sách người đang xem
tăng lên đột biến chắc chắn là có một
người nào đó gài vào đây tôi sẽ không
nói một cái gì cả vì sao nổi mình sẽ cái
mồm mình nó dễ đi xa lắm nè tôi nhờ nên
đang báo 75 ph độ
ẩm anh thì mua máy lọc à Gì à máy hút ẩm
của của
Xiaomi nhà tôi làm máy lắm đấy nên nên
là anh chả cảm nhận được cái gì
cả nhà tôi C tôi tôi hồi trước tôi có
cái suy nghĩ này tiện thể chia sẻ luôn
anh em kiểu Tôi đã từng gặp à không phải
từng gặp nữa đương nhiên là từng gặp rồi
tôi đi chơi với đi du lịch nh đi du lịch
với công ty và thấy xếp tôi xếp tôi đúng
kiểu như này xếp tổng xếp lớn mà mặc
đúng bộ kiểu đồ kiểu quần quần đùi áo
phông Hawai đấy Xong rồi đeo kí dâm với
một cái điện thoại trên tay cứ thế mà đi
à đương nhiên là có thêm cái gì À cái
kiểu ví nó kiểu Cái bó Chính xác cái bóp
hơn đấy để mà để mấy cái giấy tờ các thứ
các thứ chắc chắn là trong đấy kiểu ít
tiền mặt thể cù nắm cắt thẻ đấy th c
xong rồi cứ thế mà đi du lịch không
chuẩn bị bất kỳ cái gì cả đấy không cần
chuẩn bị một cái gì cả Xong rồi đến đến
đấy cần thay quần áo gì Ok mùa
đấy đấy chơi kiểu thế đấy là theo kiểu
đấy là một cách sống không biết chắc đấy
Không phải kiểu sống tối giản đâu mà đi
Có vẻ khá là kiểu nhẹ đầu ấy đúng không
Đỡ phải suy nghĩ về chuẩn bị gì cả đế đế
mua bởi vì xác định là đến những cái
đương nhiên là mình đi du lịch mình
không phải đến với cái nơi kiểu hoang vu
hả lánh cái gì cả mà Bọn tôi ĩ ra đều
đến những nơi kiểu cũng gọi là kiểu dạng
là nó mà thành phố hay gì gì đó nên là
có Toàn bộ dịch vụ các thứ các thứ ở đấy
đấy anh ấy đi trong tâm trạng như thế
Tôi ngược lại tôi thì Uầy mang tiếng là
đi cho dù kể cả hai ngày cho đến tận 4 n
ngày tôi vẫn xách một cái vali đi vali
to nhá xong rồi một cái ba lô đi nữa xu
trong đấy bao nhiêu đồ ông phải hiểu là
đến nỗi nhá đến nỗi lỉnh nó kiểu tôi
kiểu thích kiểu chuẩn bị một cái quá mức
đến nỗi là không không biết dùng từ quá
mức không Bởi vì tôi vẫn dùng kiểu tôi
kiểu thích chu đáo cẩn thận thôi là tôi
mang theo cả cá Lio đi và đúng hôm ấy sử
dụng được Lio thật hôm ấy tôi nằm giường
nằm à dường tầng tôi nằm ở tít tận trên
tầng ba kiểu cái ổ điện ở tầng một ấy
xong rồi Kiểu Mọi người đang bảo kiểu
thằng Long kiểu th này kiểu phải cắm sạc
phải kiểu để để máy điện thoại ở dưới
thôi không thể kiểu với lên trên được ý
Không sao chị không sao anh ạ Đấy vị các
bạn biết loa không loa là cái ổ cắm điện
ý
đấy tôi kiểu vác lý và ra cắm chữ kiểu
mặt ngỡ ngàng mọi người luôn
đấy nghĩa là tôi mang chuẩn bị đi rất
nhiều đồ thử thử như TH như
thế và cách sống của tôi hiện tại đang
là như thế đó là là mình
à Kiểu chuẩn bị mọi thứ chu đáo sắm sửa
mọi thứ khá là đầy đủ Ở nhà Ở nhà có rất
nhiều thứ đồ dùng đồ các thứ thứ nó nó
không biết dùng thử tiện hay không chắc
chắn là nó kiểu gọi là nhà chu đảo à
Kiểu gọi gì gì đó n đấy cách sống của
tôi hiện tại và tôi đang nghĩ là đươ
nhiên nó không phải tối giản gì cả nó
khá là cồng kềnh rất là cồng kềnh nhưng
mà tôi nghĩ là để đến cái mức mặt Thực
sự mà tôi cảm thấy là muốn tối giản ấ
Tôi nghĩ tôi chắc là lúc đấy tôi phải
giàu bằng xếp tôi ít nh cốn mốc Tôi cảm
thấy là như thế lúc đấy
Kiểu thích cần thì gọi như nào nhỉ đó n
ná cứ ví dụ n ná như
này thay vì các bạn mua một cái mua cái
máy giặt ở nhà to không cảnh các bạn
luôn gửi đồ nhưng mà để để
mà Để để để mà kiểu luôn gửi đồ đấy thì
nó bất tiện việc là bạn phải đi gửi đúng
không chuẩn hơn là bạn có tiền kiểu thuê
người du việc để làm việc đấy cho bạn
đấy Nghĩa là đến phải cái mức là kiểu
như thế hoặc chỉ đơn giản là thuê người
giú việc để giặt đồ bạn Nói chung là cái
bạn không cần quan tâm về việc là là có
Có cần phải mua cái máy giặt hay không
nữa ấ vì bạn không bao giờ phải làm việc
việc đấy nữa ấ không phải tự thân làm
việc đấy nữa Ý tôi là như thế đến cái
mức giàu như
thế thì thì tôi chơi còn không thì bây
giờ tôi vẫn sẽ cố sắm ở nhà cũng lắm đồ
để cho khi nào cần thì mình lôi ra dùng
đấy
đấy theo quan điểm của tôi ờ không biết
mấy ông qu điểm nào thì mấy ông cứ chia
sẻ thôi anh em giao lưu trao đổi mà tôi
tôi rất là kiểu tôi hướng ngoại
à không biết dùng từ hướng ngoại đúng
hay không nhưng là tôi không ngại chia
sẻ nên là tôi sẽ chia sẻ rất nhiều góc
nhìn và chia sẻ Thật lòng các thứ các
thứ Nên là mấy ông cũng không nên ngại
mấy ông cứ thẳng thắn anh em ngồi trò
chuyện với nhau
sẻ đấy nó rất là hay Tôi cảm thấy rất là
hay việc tôi nói ra mấy cái đấy có thể
quan điểm sai xong mấy ông hoàn toàn có
thể sửa tôi thì tôi sẽ biết à tôi sai
tôi sửa thì tôi sẽ cải thiện được thêm
các nhìn các thứ thử Còn khi mà ai cũng
giữ khăng khăng cái suy nghĩ của mình
đúng không ạ Không bộc lộ ra thì mình
còn chẳng biết được mình sai người khác
Chẳng biết được mình sai để mà sửa đúng
không ạ Đấy nên là tôi nghĩ tôi cứ nói
ra mọi thứ nó Tôi không nói việc là đúng
chắc chắn chắc chắn rồi kể cả dù tôi có
dạy mấy ông không có nghĩa là mọi lời
tôi nói đều đúng đúng không ạ Tôi có thể
kiểu hơn tuổi mấy ông hai gì đó kinh
nghiệm hơn mà chắc gì trong này chắc là
có nhiều người hơn tuổi hay mọi thứ hơn
rồi
có ông xin việc mãi không được
Ờ nó như nào nhỉ Nó giống như việc tôi
thường hay bảo mấy ông cái việc tìm được
công việc hay thậm chí phỏng vấn nó cũng
giống như có ng yêu vậy Một là mấy ông
thứ nhất là mấy ông xác định được mục
tiêu rồi mấy ông Phấn đấu đến cùng hai
là mấy ông phải đi thả thính giải thính
bay lung túng xem chúng ai ai cắn câu
thì cắn nhưng mà thính của ông nó phải
chất lượng tí vì ai cũng thả ai cũng
giải rồi đúng không đấy thì Ông phải
nâng cao trình độ hay mọi thứ sao cho
luôn luôn phù hợp chứ không phải ông chỉ
cắm đầu và Đi giải rồi ông cứ hy vọng
đúng không ạ Ông trong thời gian đấy Ông
vẫn
phải nâng cao cái chất lượng của bản
thân
tôi V vừa sửa cv cho vài bạn xong vài
bạn ghi cv cho dù là tôi có ghi tôi có
ghi kiểu vào trong discord là kiểu thỉnh
thoảng tôi gửi CV tôi chia sẻ các thứ
thứ rồi nhưng mà các bạn đương nhiên là
cũng không
không và đọc mấy nhưng mà thực sự thì
các bạn vẫn còn bị mấy cái lỗi tôi thấy
khá là cơ bản khi mà viết CV đây Để tôi
tìm lại tin nhắn tôi gửi
cho tế nhờ tôi không có để lộ thông tin
thì bạn đây nên chả không sao
bạn tôi vừa m mới góp ý nhá g này này
góp ý tận bảy mục thì mấy ông sẽ thấy là
kểu cũng nhiều cái Đúng
không Một là bạn ấy để ảnh kể D chưa
chuyên nghiệp lắm bạn tự chụp hình như
là chụp bằng căm trước điện thoại đấy Ờ
n đây nên đi chụp ảnh th hai là bạn dùng
sẵn cái template của cái mấy cái trang
vcv thành ra là kiểu nên là ghi đầy đủ
hết có thể thành ra nó lại kiểu bị khi
mà Bạn ghi đầy đủ quá Thấy nó Nó kiểu bị
dài mà kiểu bị thừa ấ ví dụ tự nhiên Bạn
ghi thêm phần giới
tính được tên tên các bạn và thêm ảnh
các bạn chắc là đổ đặc biệt thì không
cần phải ghi giới tính th các bạn chẳng
quan trọng giới tính luôn Thậm chí các
bạn kiểu giấy tính không còn nhất thiết
phải Nam nữ mà đúng không thoải mái mà
công việc đấy đâu phải là yêu cầu chỉ
tuyển nam hay chỉ tuyển nữ đâu đấy ngày
sinh cũng bỏ qua này số điện thoại của
cũng bỏ qua này ngày sinh thì nói chung
là mấy ông quan điểm nhá đó là mấy ông
giải civ này đi khắp nơi n là nên là có
những cái thông tin cá nhân của mấy ông
không cần cho tất cả mọi người cù biết
đúng không ạ Nó còn để bị lội thông tin
mà nên tốt nhất là mấy cái đấy tôi cảm
thấy không cần đương nhiên là khi mà ông
nộp hẳn vào một công ty rồi ông chính
thức làm công ty rồi thì lúc đấy đương
nhiên là có một cái giấy tờ thông tin
chi tiết về con người ông thì lúc đấy sẽ
nộp sau đúng không ạ Còn mấy cái CV thì
thì đơn thuần là việc là ông sẽ giới
thiệu cho người kia ông là con người
kiểu đã đã có kinh nghiệm làm gì như thì
chỉ nên dừng lại mức độ đấy thôi đừng có
quá nhiều thêm thông tin nhện cảm số
điện thoại tôi nói vài lần rồi đó là thự
ra là một công ty chuẩn chuyên nghiệp ấ
người ta không liên hệ lại với ông qua
số điện thoại mà qua email công ty nào
mà liên hệ lại ông qua số điện thoại thì
công ty đị n phải xem xét lại nói thế
thẳng là như thế nên thành ra là không
cần phải để số điện thoại đ cho người ta
làm gì cả link Facebook á Đúng tôi có để
link Facebook ở trên CV của tôi bởi vì
Facebook của tôi tính ra tôi đã cố tình
làm từ lâu gần trước trước đây trẻ trâu
không nói nhưng mà mấy bài đấy chắc cũng
không công khai mọi người thấy
đâu Facebook của tôi tôi đã xây dựng
hình ảnh khá ổn rồi may mà chưa có mấy
cái ảnh bìa được kiểu đa cấp hay kiểu
các thứ thử đấy không thì nó còn thể
phãi trưởng hơn đấy thì nên là tôi tự
tin được để link Facebook nó là một phần
hình ảnh chứ còn nếu mà nick Facebook
của ông mà hay chia sẻ mấy cái dướ
status thất tình ý hoặc là gì gì đó ấy
tốt nhất là không nên để
đấy tiếp theo không nên dùng email cá
nhân à Mấy cái email mà đôi khi còn dính
ở ngày tháng n sinh này họ email kiểu
gì kiểu email à khi anh yêu chịu trái
tim tan
vỡ đấy Kiểu thế không
đấy tạo email công việc thường là kiểu
ví dụ bạn ấy tên là Luân thì tôi để bạn
luân de như này đơn giản thế Đúng rồi JV
đấy m không cần nên để sở thích làm gì
cả trừ khi trừ khi mấy ông kiểu vào công
ty thì biết được công ty đấy cũng kiểu
vui vui kiểu anh em với nhau và mà ông
xác định là vào công ty đấy cũng để hòa
đồng vui anh em chứ không phải để nghĩa
là vừa làm việc vừa vui ấ thì mấy ông
thể để s đích giống như là kiểu thích
chơi game thích đá bóng hay cá gì gì đó
đôi khi nó một điểm cộm đôi khi th nhá
Đấy đấy phần Kỹ năng ấy thì đánh giá tôi
tôi tôi từng nói rồi Tôi đánh giá không
Phả cao cái phần Kỹ năng lắm mấy ông
Điền kỹ năng của mấy ông kiểu làm này
tốt này xôi thậm chí là pp Tôi vẫn nhớ
Có ông để p 10 sao Chưa hiểu kiểu Uầy
thế phải Master lắm Hay là chỉ 10 sao
đối với trình độ à với vợ tự ông ấy Kiểu
cảm thấy là ông M sao chưa biết được Rốt
cuộc mấy ông để mấy cái điểm kỹ năng đấy
dựa trên tiêu chí
nào nếu mà thực sự dựa theo một cái gì
đó thì mấy ông phải có chứng chỉ xác
nhận nó còn không thì tôi thấy là toàn
bộ phần Kỹ năng ấy Trừ trừ tiếng Anh thì
có thể là trong phần kinh nghiệm không
đề cập thì ông thể g à Thì ông có thể
ghi thêm vào còn toàn bộ kỹ năng khác
tôi cảm thấy là kiểu ví dụ là kỹ năng pp
hay là HTML hay CS thì thực ra phần kinh
nghiệm ông cũng phải nói là ông đã làm
dự án gì ông áp dụng công nghệ gì trong
đấy có hết rồi nên là
phần phần Kỹ năng không bao giờ nên tôi
cảm thấy không nên
ghi đúng là kiểu mấy ông ghi vào chỉ cho
nhiều chữ hơn chứ thực ra là người ta
nhìn vào người ta không bao giờ nhìn vào
sở thích cái kỹ năng đâu
thật thường tôi bảo chỉ ghi kỹ năng mềm
ở trong đấy một là nhưng mà gọi như
này Hôm qua tôi bảo bạn ấy bỏ phần kỹ
năng đi vì tôi cảm thấy là kiểu bạn này
vẫn còn hơi non quá mà bạn ấy ghi kỹ
năng có vẻ kiểu nó bị dập khuôn xịn ấy
kiểu sử dụng sử dụng à
à công cụ văn phòng Tiên học thành thạo
này xong rồi à Ờ thuyết trình tốt rồi
làm việc nhóm
tốt mấy ông đang tuyển ph mấy ông đang
đang ứng tuyển fester Tôi không tin là
mấy ông cái trình độ làm việc nhóm làm
việc team của mấy ông tốt vì tính ra mấy
ông đã có kinh nghiệm đi làm đâu không
làm làm mấy cái đấy ở đâu Làm mấy cái
đấy Ở đồ án ở trường à Kiểu team Quốc à
Không Tôi không đánh giá cao với cái đấy
nên bỏ bỏ bỏ bỏ bỏ
Ờ kiểu bạn ấy ghi rõ là mục tiêu là
trong vòng mnh thang tới thì sẽ là ở mức
freser mấy thằng tới ở mức senio hay gì
gì đó tôi cảm à Ở nh mức Junior gì gì đó
tôi C cảm thấy có đnh ra cao cái mục
tiêu đấy lắm mục tiêu chuẩn thì Ừ chắc
là cái đoạn đấy Hơi khuôn mẫu một tí tôi
vẫn Tôi bảo là mấy bạn tham nên tham
khảo mẫu vì thực ra nó vẫn chung chung
là mình mục tiêu là
bản thân như thế nào không phải là mỗi
chức danh cũng như là cái mục tiêu bạn
ấy để hơi thấp Tôi cảm thấy hơi thấp nên
là tôi bảo bỏ đi
Đấy kinh nghiệm B bảo là vì em là sinh
viên nên em mới chỉ làm những dự án gì
gì đó nên tôi bảo bỏ qua phần giới
thiệu tên công nghệ thì tôi cảm thấy có
rất nhiều ông ghi công nghệ đang dùng
một cách rất là hời hợt cho kiểu là hoặc
là đôi khi viết sai Thực ra chứng tôi từ
viết sai rồi jquery Như này chẳng hạn
chữ j là không viết hoa đâu nhá phải như
này mới đúng nhá Đấy x rồi Hoặc là m ghi
ghi kiểu HTML như này pp như này không
đừng ghi kiểu này nó viết hoa nó có lý
do nó đấy Nên là mấy ông một khi đã ghi
thì phải ghi kiểu đúng chuẩn nó kiểu cái
viết Hoa phải viết đúng Nói chung là
kiểu Tôi cảm thấy là nó nó là cái sự
cháu chuốt thôi Tôi tin là tôi thường
tôi có nói rồi đó là khi mấy ông cho
chuốt làm mấy cái kiểu văn bản các thứ
thứ thuần như này
ấ Tuy là rõ ràng đây không phải công
việc chính của mấy ông mấy ông ngồi cốt
mà Nhưng mà thực thực ra nó vẫn là chữ
thôi Cái Việ việc tính cách của mấy ông
cho chuốt như thế thì code của mấy ông
sẽ cẩn thận cho chuốt Tôi cảm thấy là
những cái ông mà làm văn bảo hời hợt các
thứ thứ như này này kiểu nó hứng thế này
hứng thế kia ấy Ui Cố mấy ông ấy đúng
như thế luôn cố ông đấy hứng lên chỗ này
một kia hứng lên chỗ kia một kểu nó
không nó không kiểu thống nhất nó kiểu
dạng là nhở nó kiểu bị bị gọi nh nhở sơ
sải chẳng biết dùng từ như nà
nhiều từ kiểu kiểu
thế tôi cảm thấy là kiểu mình mình phải
tôi quan điểm là kiểu một là không làm
hai là phải làm nó tốt nên là đúng là
nhiều lúc tôi cũng hơi lười để Bởi vì
tôi biết được khi mà tôi làm ấy thì phải
làm rất tốn thời gian vì rất là phải cẩn
thận nên là lúc mà tôi làm C hay làm
powerp tôi làm Phải mất ba 4 tiếng đ cẩn
thận ắ kiểm tra đi kiểm tra lại đế là
từng cái kiểu lùi đầu dòng các thứ các
thứ phải mở cái ruler m thước kẻ lên này
đo từng cái từng cái một xong rồi đo
từng cái phone các thứ thứ đương nhiên
là mình dùng cái mấy cái mặc định của
Word thì nó cũng kiểu phone nếu heading
nếu cái gì gì đó rồi heading 1 heading 2
heading 3 làm mọi thứ cẩn thận hết rồi
Nếu vẫn phải đi kiểm tra lại các thứ Cẩn
thận tôi thấy nhiều người không làm cái
đấy nên là thành ra kiểu họ bị thiếu cẩn
thận trong cả công việc luôn Thế không
MN chứng chỉ của bạn đấy thì bạn ấy ghi
là chứng chỉ mấy cái chứng chỉ tin học
hay chứng chỉ văn phòng gì gì đó thì tôi
bảo Xóa đi các bạn chỉ cần nên C các bạn
một khi đã khoe ấ thì đấy bạn ấy có cái
chứng chỉ về
tox mà được Kiểu một nơi nào đó Công
nhận kiểu dạng có có tờ giấy chứng chỉ h
đàng hoàng ấy thì có thể ghi vào và thêm
một vài chính trỉ khác nữa còn không thì
không thì bỏ đi được Nói chung là nếu mà
bạn bỏ hết Giống như là tôi đang bảo bạn
này bỏ đi hết mấy bạn thấy sơ sài không
ạ sơ sài thì đúng vì thức a của bạn đang
chỉ có thế vậy làm th nào để bớt sơ sai
thì các bạn phải ghi thêm rất nhiều thứ
vào trong phần kinh nghiệm này này nghĩa
là tôi bảo bạn ấy phải làm thêm một cái
project nữa Tính ra bạn mới làm hai
Project và việc mô tả là bạn đ đã làm
những cái gì nó bị vẫn bị sơ sài luôn vì
tôi thấy là bạn ấy làm như mới chỉ mức
cơ bản cud nĩa là thêm sử Xóa thôi cũng
chưa xử lý bài toán nghiệp vụ gì cả đấy
nghĩa là chính bạn đấy cũng đang sơ sài
về cái việc cái công việc Cái quan trọng
nhất là bạn đi apply là cái công việc
lập trình đúng không kinh nghiệm này
quan trọng nhất này cái thứ đầu tiên
người ta nhìn vào này đấy thì cái này
bạn đấy cũng bị sơ sải thì cái đấy Bắt
buộc phải phải sửa phải chấn trỉnh
Ờ cái này
Ừ thường tôi tôi nghĩ nếu mà sinh viên
ấy thì đặc biệt sinh viên của tôi từng
làm hoặc chính tôi thôi tậ ti làm cái
project đầu tiên để mình hiểu qua về
ngôn ngữ lập trình này làm Project thứ
hai để nâng cao hơn một tí kiểu chuyên
sâu hơn tí này và nó nên có bài toán
nghiệp vụ này Nhưng đấy Hai cái project
đấy là hai Project ở trên trường làm nhá
Và đôi khi là làm việc theo nhóm nhá
Nhưng mình vẫn nên một cái project nữa
Project nữa thì hoàn toàn mở nó là nên
là pet Project nĩa là Project nó tương
đối nhỏ thôi và nó mang Thiên hướng là
theo sở thích cá nhân nghĩa là ông thích
làm cái gì ông làm ví dụ Giả sử trước
tôi thích về mảng Facebook Facebook tôi
làm những cái pet Project về Facebook
làm tool Facebook
đấy Làm kiểu hoặc là đơn giản là tôi
thích ảnh cái xh đ nên cắt nhá Không
biết cắt kiểu gì ch t có như ai đ cắt
cái đoạn này thì tôi thích là ảnh cái x
kiểu thích ngắm thì tôi nghĩ là có nhiều
người có chung sở thích thì tôi Hồi đấy
tôi làm cái con chatbot để nhắn nó thì
nó tự động gửi ảnh các thứ thì tôi lấy
ảnh ở từ api rồi tôi bắn lên api của
chatbot Vân Vân Vân đấy đấy tôi tự tìm
hiểu rất nhiều Nói chung là mình có nhu
cầu mình nghĩ ra bài toán mình nghĩ ra
giải pháp các thứ thứ để làm ra là một
sản phẩm Người Người ta có thể sử dụng
được thì thì đấy là ổn rồi có thứ thì
khoe rồi đúng không ạ bài toán nghiệm vụ
là sao Anh á Nghĩa là nghĩa là nó phải
xử lý hóc búa một tí nó phải thực tế một
tí có rất nhiều ông làm mấy cái sản phẩm
mà Nói thẳng luôn là nó nó vô dụng cho
rồi kìa không quan tâm về việc của bạn
đã làm được bao lâu không quan tâm việc
code bạn hể xịn như nào vô dụng bởi vì
nó không áp dụng được thực
tế các bạn phải thc phải xem là
trên Bây giờ là phần mềm n cả trong web
có nhan nhản rồi đúng không ạ Mấy ông
phải lên hẳn với cái trang web đấy để
xem ví dụ Giả sử Giả sử nhá Mấy ông thấy
có ai làm trang web bán ô tô không ạ bán
ô tô nhá nghĩa là chỉ lên đấy trả tiền m
mấy tỷ trong một cái ô tô ấy không chạ
người ta đi mua cái gì đắt thì người ta
sẽ phải đến trực tiếp người ta xem thì
rõ ràng cái trang web bán ô tô Đấy nó
phi thực tế rồi hồi trước tôi vẫn nhớ
cái quả của ông làm trang web thuê
chuyện xong rồi tiền tiền thuê để quá
luôn cả tiền
mua thôi cảm thấy Hoặc là ông ấy làm
trang web về
à Kiểu n tôi tôi tôi nói thế mấy ông
không dễ hình dung thôi nghĩa là ám chẻ
nó thứ nhất là nó bài toán nó không thực
tế từ không thực tế nên thành ra bạn ấy
không phân tích để suy luận ra được cần
giải quyết thế nào vân vân bạn không
giải quyết được bài toán nên là cứ áp
dụng những cái bài toán mà hiển nhiên là
trên mạng đầy các phần mềm Rồi ví dụ là
ờ quản lý một cái gì đó là nó cũng tương
đối khó này quản lý sinh viên này quản
lý nhân viên này Đấy quản lý ở đây không
phải là thêm thử Xóa mỗi Nhân viên đâu
nhá mà sẽ phải là nó phải sâu hơn tí nó
phải Kiểu nó phải là đây tôi hôm trước
tôi có nói V sinh viên Đó là một phần
mềm Ấy chuẩn là nó sẽ kiểu là đương
nhiên là nó sẽ thực ra nó cũng chỉ có ba
ba quy trình thôi Nó input process và
output nó đơn giản là như
thế input là đầu vào đúng không ạ là
người dùng sẽ người
dùng nhập dữ liệu vào đấy xong rồi xử lý
đúng không ạ v sẽ xử lý xử lý dữ liệu
chính xác là chuẩn là người dùng nhập
thông tin
vào xử lý thông
tin để biến hành dữ
liệu tại sao lại khái niệm thông tin về
dữ liệu nhiều người bị nhầm lẫn hai khái
niệm này thông tin nghĩa là người dùng
có thể nhập vào rất nhiều thứ link
tating có cái đúng cái kiểu dạng cái
thừa cái thừa thứ Nhưng mà mình sẽ biến
nó thành dữ liệu cái dữ liệu Nó là kiểu
dạng là nó là những cái thông thông tin
đã qua xử lý đơn nản thôi Nếu mà
dịch nói kểu thô là như thế nhưng mà cứ
hình dung cứ hình dung nhá Tôi tôi gửi
cho thằng chat VT này cả một đoạn văn
bản rất là dài các thứ thứ thì nó sẽ
kiểu phải xử lý cái đống thông tin đấy
để hiểu được à thực ra mày cần cái gì
đúng không đấy để biến hành và thậm chí
là lưu lại ví dụ Giả sử tôi gửi đoạn văn
bản rất dài đấy nhưng nó thể sàng lọc
được từ đấy nó biết được tên của cái ông
này là gì ông đấy giới tính là gì ông ấy
có nhu cầu gì Vân vân vân Thì đấy là
biến thành dữ liệu đấy chứ không phải là
tôi gửi cho nó thế nà nó lưu đúng như
thế thì đấy nó là chưa qua xử lý và nó
sẽ chỉ là thông tin thôi đấy hồi tôi
được học tin họp vong người ta dạy
như thế không biết mấy ông được dạy như
nào đấy và output rất nhiều người làm
vẫn chỉ dừng ở mức độ là kiểu người dùng
nhập như nào thì hiển thị ra đúng như
thế thế người dùng không thèm dùng phần
mềm của ông luôn dùng word hay Excel nó
còn xịn hơn dùng PowerPoint nó còn màu m
hơn đúng không ạ Chuẩn là người dùng
nhập vào một kiểu mình phải trả về cái
phải gọi là trả về không biết dùng đúng
không kiểu đưa cho người dùng những dữ
liệu mà họ cần thậm chí họ còn không
biết họ cần đấy thế này quá đẳng cấp
luôn V ví dụ nhá ví dụ nhá
Ờ cứ nói bài toán về phần
mềm quản lý sinh viên của trường đi của
trường đấy nghĩa là người dùng sẽ nhập
thông tin của sinh viên vào đấy rồi nhập
điểm của sinh viên nhập các môn đầy đủ
tất cả các môn nhập ngành của sinh viên
đấy sinh viên đấy học lớp nào ngành nào
đúng không ạ xong rồi Hồi đấy tôi làm
cái phần mềm đấy Xong rồi tôi in ra
không phải in ra mỗi danh sách sinh viên
mỗi danh sách điểm không Tôi in ra thống
kê được là trong lớp đấy có bao nhiêu
sinh viên à Đủ điểm tốt nghiệp rồi bao
nhiêu sinh viên cần thi lại môn này môn
này bao nhiêu sinh viên cần thi lại kiể
đang chưa nhập điểm hay các thứ đại khái
như thế đấy là những cái mà họ cần đấy
những cái mà Excel làm rất là khó đúng
không ạ Chứ việc là nhập vào như nào y
nó đúng như thế thì mấy ông không có
tuổi với thằng Excel luôn đúng không ạ
đấy Cái đấy Cái phần mềm mà nó liên quan
đến xử lý dữ liệu và người dùng họ còn
không biết họ cần và khi mà họ dùng rồi
họ sẽ cảm thấy à Nó xịn hơn đ Excel ta
phải dùng phần mềm này ta không dùng
Excel nữa V Excel nó làm cho tao phải
suy nghĩ nhiều phải xử lý rất là nhiều
còn đây tao chỉ nhập vào abc nó in ra
được cho tao x yz Thậm chí còn hơn nữa
những cái thứ mà tao thực sự cần đúng
không ạ Thì đấy là phần mềm gọi là phần
mềm gọi là sử dụng áp dụng được vào
trong thực tế và người dùng cần người
dùng muốn đổi từ cái từ những cái mà
người dùng đang dùng truyền thống giống
như là kiểu nhiều nơi còn đang điểm danh
bằng giấy bút chẳng hạn tôi biết một vài
trường như thế nhá đấy nhưng mà Hồi đấy
tôi làm phần mềm đấy là cho giáo viên
điểm danh ở trên phần mềm nó sẽ sẽ hiển
thị ra đầy đủ danh sách sinh viên sinh
viên này đang sắp phải thi lại nếu mà
cho hôm nay nó muộn à một buổi nghỉ nữa
nó thi lại bạn có đồng ý không đấy ng
thế
Đấy xong rồi Kiểu Điền ra Điền xong mấy
cái đấy còn chấm công giáo viên luôn g
viên đã đã điểm danh vào hôm nay được
chấm công để cuối tháng kiểu quyết tà
kiểu tàn lương các thử thứ đấy Đấy là
một cái phần mềm phần mềm áp dụng được
bài toán thực tế nhưng mà để mà làm được
điều đấy đương nhiên thứ nhất bạn phải
có phải khảo sát thị trường phải khảo
sát thực sự là người dùng đang gặp vấn
đề gì đang cần gì hoặc là bắt trước một
cái phần mềm nào đó trên mạng các thứ để
làm để các bạn tự nghĩ ra một cái phần
mềm nó rất là khó bởi khi các bạn chưa
có kinh nghiệm đúng không ạ và các bạn
đấy tôi thấy nhiều bạn có không không
biết được cái đoạn Ừ cũng biết được
input rồi cũng biết được process rồi
nhưng mà không biết output mình không
biết được là đưa cho người dùng cái gì
nên cứ trả về chung chung trả về hết
toàn bộ những cái thông tin mà người
dùng đã nhập đấy Kiểu thế nghĩ rằng phần
mềm mình thế là quá ngon
rồi không Thế thì người ta người ta tội
gì phải dùng phần mềm các bạn bởi vì
người ta đang quản bản thân bạn còn phải
tư duy nữa nhá Đó là bản thân là trước
khi có phần mềm các bạn Họ đang dùng cái
gì đúng không ạ ạ Tại sao họ phải nhảy
sang phần mềm các bạn nó phải hơn cái gì
so v cái cũ chứ đúng không ạ Họ đang
nhập một đống thông tin vào trong cái cũ
ví dụ đăng nhập hết thông tin ởo trong
Word hay Excel cũ rồi tự nhiên dùng phần
mềm bạn họ lại phải nhập lại từ đầu à Nó
bị kiểu sao đúng không nên là phần mềm
của các bạn mà hỗ trợ được việc là các
bạn mà họ có thể chuyển đổi từ cái Word
hay Excel ấy vào phần mềm các bạn nhanh
để họ đỡ mất công nhập lại thì càng tốt
hơn nữa đấy nên là Nói chung là kiểu
mình cứ tư duy việc là làm sao tiện nhất
cho người dùng đương nhiên là khổ cho
mình khổ bởi vì mình phải làm việc nhiều
hơn nhưng mà càng tiện người dùng thì
lương các bạn sẽ càng
cao Nói chung là cái số tiền trả các bạn
sẽ càng xứng đáng Còn nếu mà các bạn
chính bản thân các bạn cũng lười các bạn
nghĩ là thôi người dùng thế là đủ đủ cần
rồi không cần hơn nữa thì người dùng sẽ
phải khi mà người dùng mà phải suy nghĩ
quá nhiều làm cái phần mềm bạn ấy thì
lương bạn thấp thế thôi
Ui nãy gi ngồi
kiểu th cảm tôi Tôi sắp đi dậy tôi lại
quay lại cái quả máu nhập về cái kiểu đi
dậy thôi cách nói chuyện đấy cách nói
chuyện cũng giống cách tôi đi dậy trên
trường đấy tôi cũng nói đúng kiểu thế
thôi không không xưng hô nó cũng giống
à bài toán cần những yếu tố và
gì để đi thực tập từ năm 2 nă 3 sinh
viên
thì đấy thì cứ làm thêm các phần các
kiểu Project các thứ thứ các dự án các
thứ làm thêm phần mềm để
kiểu kiểu để mà mình nâng ca năng lực ở
các thứ và chuyên môn
nữa ừ năm Nếu mà Giả sử bạn 54 mới ra
trường thì tôi khuyên là bạn 54 mới đi
thực tập các bạn bây giờ ham bị đi thực
tập sớm ấy cho rồi Các bạn đang chưa có
một cái gì cả mọi thứ kiểu không ấy các
bạn đến đấy cũng đừng H vọng là người ta
sẽ sẽ cầm tay chỉ lối các bạn chẳng có
ai có nghĩa kiểu được trả tiền để làm vụ
đấy Cả họ cũng được trả lương để mà ngồi
làm việc của họ thôi họ không trách
nhiệm phải kiểu hướng dẫn đào tạo các
bạn nên thành ra là rất nhiều bạn kiểu
đi xong các bạn còn bị nản các bạn bỏ ấy
vì rõ ràng là đi thực tập không hề vui
hay là mọi thứ đương nhiên là mình cũng
rất là lo mình kiểu muốn ra trường sớm
rồi Kiểu muốn làm gì đó kiếm hay gì đó
nó thực sự là xác định là
mình phải gọi là đủ lông đủ cánh đã mới
bay đúng không Đấy nghĩa bạn phải cải
thiện rất nhiều và phải đợi Nói chung là
kể cả dù ngon lắm rồi Tôi nghĩ là vẫn là
năm cuối khi là năm cuối khoảng thời
gian bạn sẽ có rất rất nhiều để bạn thể
được tập hoặc làm gì đó nữa chứ còn năm
năm HA năm ba thì cứ làm thêm rất nhiều
Project hoặc là đấy nhận freelancer làm
thêm một vài cái dự án cái gì đó cũng
đạm anh nhỉ Ừ nó cũng dần bão hỏa nhưng
mà tính ra nó vẫn gọi là như nà dùng từ
hot thì nó vẫn đúng bởi vì tôi thấy là
nhu cầu kể cả kể cả công ty vừa đuổi
việc người này vẫn hoàn toàn có thể
tuyển thêm người khác nếu mà người đấy
tiêm năng
Ờ nó vẫn nằm ở bài toán việc là cái hố
trước thì nguồn cung thiếu nên là kiểu
nó thành hot con giờ nguồn cung chất
lượng Vẫn thiếu Tôi thấy vẫn thiếu bạn
Nói chung là kiểu ông cách để mà ông
biết rõ nhất ấy ông chỉ cần xem vào
chính mấy bạn HR thôi Bây giờ bạn thấy
HR ngành nào cao nhất tôi cảm thấy tôi
chắc là tôi dẫn đp Nhưng mà tôi thấy HR
it là nhan nhản luôn Chứng tỏ là là kiểu
người ta cần tuyển it nhiều hơn thế nên
kiểu HR nhiều h thế
đấy Ừ nhỉ cách đấy là một cách hay để mà
mình đánh giá đấy mình đánh giá một cái
thị trướng HR ở cái ngành nào đông thì
chứng tỏ là ngành đấy Vẫn đang
không biết gì rồi không biết gì rồi là
nhà cứ sai sai hình tôi quen bạn này
phải mà nhìn tôi không giỏi nhớ tên nó
lắm avatar ông đấy thì quay mặt đi tôi
khó mà đánh giá được nhận ra không Ờ sao
em thầy công ty mua tiền khói ra Thầy
đang tuyển mãi mà không nhận được người
ô khi họ cũng có thể một là họ trả cái
đãi ngộ mà thử cũng thấp nên thành ra
khó người Kiểu muốn vào hai là họ đấy
Đặt tiêu chuẩn cao các thứ các thứ bởi
vì nhiều người giỏi Họ cũng khá là được
giữ lại ở ở những công ty khác rồi nên
là bây giờ tuyển
xo kiểu khó
phết
một bố à 99 Bách Khoa chả biết gì cũng
sắp rồi anh đi được 4
tháng ông ghi tiếng Việt không dấu tập
không hiểu lắm nhưng mà đúng nếu mà các
bạn nhìn
vào nhiều nơi bây giờ kiểu nhiều Ông bỏ
các thứ thứ phết đừng bị nhột chí bởi
mấy người đấy mình lại nghĩ là có thêm
cơ hội cho mình thôi nó là bài toán thực
ra tính là mấy ông vẫn đang đấu đá nhau
ngay tại bây giờ
mà mình có công việc này đồng nghĩa là
việc là có một người không có công việc
đúng không
ạ Anh đánh giá sao về cơ hội làm bên an
toàn Các bạn cứ hỏi tôi đánh giá chẳng
biết đánh giá gì cả ông hỏi chat vity
khi đánh giá chuẩn hơn tôi đấy
Ờ ok
thầy có rất nhiều cái hai từ việc là nói
như
này Nói chung là thầy tôi thì kiểu dạng
là từ trước nay
kiểu luôn muốn làm lớn xong
rồi Thầy cũng luôn là người tiên phong
thầy Đúng là một leader chuẩn chuẩn mực
luôn ấy kiểu
vì rất nhiều người kiểu khi làm chủ rồi
họ sẽ kiểu quen kiểu ra lệnh xong rồi
Kiểu không quan tâm đến nhân viên Vân
Vân đúng không ạ Còn đây là người luôn
là đầu tàu kiểu
dạng là kiểu đồng hành cùng anh em anh
em khó khăn Đúng Nghĩa nhá Đúng Nghĩa
nghĩa
là ví dụ ví dụ Giả sử Hôm nay tôi có
việc tôi không dạy được thầy sẽ vào dạy
thay đấy chỉ một cái nho nhỏ đấy thôi
nghĩa là chỉ kiểu là anh em bị ngã ở đâu
thầy sẽ luôn ở đấy đỡ anh em để mà hỗ
trợ được anh em cũng không không đòi hỏi
không dùng từ đò Hỏi không đúng Nói
chung là không kiểu chech móc
không áp lực gì cả anh em cần cái gì thì
mình sẽ nhảy vào giúp đỡ hộ kiểu
kiểu và nói chung là luôn tâm lý các thử
các thử và có tầm nhìn nữa quan trọng
tôi thấy là người sếp có tầm nhìn tầm
nhìn ở đây cứ nói chung chung thế Thế
rốt cuộc tầm nhìn là gì đúng không ạ bây
giờ thử nói đơn giản nhé cái trường cũ
đấy của tôi Tôi cảm thấy là tầm nhìn
thấy đúng là theo kiểu là với tôi quan
điểm nhá đó là trường học thức
âm cứ hỏi quan điểm mấy ông đi theo mấy
ông thì trường học thì cái gọi nhỉ đối
tượng quan trọng nhất nó là gì
giờ mới trả hết
có play playlist để em thể học lại chứ
anh kèm 11 thì anh cũng khó mà kèm được
anh cần như anh chỉ là người định hướng
thôi chứ thực ra tự học Thì vẫn là do
các bạn đúng bạn kia trải đúng cái mục
cái đối tượng quan trọng nhất của trường
học Vy như học sinh sau đó thì có thể
giáo viên sinh các thứ Nói chung là với
tôi quan điểm là trường sẽ phải luôn đề
cao học sinh và giáo
viên thế nhưng mà có phải kiểu dạng là
nhiều người không không hiểu được hiểu
đấy phải nên thành ra mọi người kiểu làm
cho kiểu dạng cái môi trường đấy nó
không ổn để mà giáo dục Tôi cảm thấy
cả đấy
Ờ à
Xóa và Hôm đấy thầy có nói về cái chất
riêng của mình nữa
muốn đi dậy đặc biệt về sao em muốn làm
diễn giả thì em nên có cái chất riêng
của em nó không Không cần phải kiểu gọi
nhờ nó nên là chính em không nên động
hàng bất kỳ ai không nên kiểu bắt trước
ai quá không là phiên kiểu bản sao của
một ai đúng không
Ờ và không gọi như là em có thể phát
triển hình ảnh nhưng mà nó kiểu không
cần phải kiểu gọi như quá hình ảnh à
Không biết dùng từ nha như đại khái Thì
hôm đấy thầy có nói đó chỉ thực ra là
rất nhiều người bây giờ đang muốn đánh
bóng tên tuổi bánh bóng cái hình ảnh
mình lên Nhưng mà thực sự là nó bị quá
nhan nhản rồi đặc biệt là thời buổi bây
giờ thời buổi Khi mà mọi thứ trên mạng
nó bị tin giả quá nhiều thế thành ra là
cái việc đáng bóng hình ảnh đấy nó cũng
không nó nó kiểu dạng là nó còn làm phản
pháo nó kiểu tác dụng ngược kiểu bây giờ
nhìn CV hay mọi thứ người khác trông
ngầu thế đôi khi mình không tin đúng
không ạ Mình cảm thấy kiểu có thể nó
chém gió nên là thực ra mình không quan
trọng không nên quá quan trọng về việc
ăn mặc kiểu dạng là phải lúc nào phải
sáng chạm lịch sự Sang Chảnh hay là kiểu
phải tậu cái gì gì đó giống như là thầy
nói thấy xong rồi Tôi cảm thấy là thầy
cũng là một con người thế thật nghĩ là
thầy rất là giỏi nhưng mà tính là thầy
không gọi nh thầy không đánh bóng tên
tuổi nên là mấy ông không tra được tên
thầy và đặc biệt là thầy còn dùng tên
giả nữa Bây giờ tôi không biết tên thật
của thầy không ai biết được thông tin
thật của thầy luôn thầy ẩn danh ngoài
trưởng không dùng Facebook book không
không đi ầm diễn ra không làm gì nổi bật
cả à không phải không làm gì nổi bật mà
không nổi bật trên mạng xã hội đấy nhưng
mà thầy rất là giỏi thầy làm việc toàn
với tập đoàn lớn với kiểu các thầy hiệu
trưởng của các trường lớn thế đấy giống
như là liên kết được với đại học Bách
Khoa Đó là một cái rất là lớn rồi đấy
à và nhìn Thầy ăn mặt rất là giản dị Mọi
thứ rất là giản dị luôn thầy vẫn còn đi
con xe kiểu x vaii trưởng nó TM buổi Tôi
vẫn nhớ cái hồi mà biết thầy kiểu đế như
là thầy làm mấy công việc đấy đương
nhiên là thầy cũng kiểu cứ chò lắm tiền
đi nhưng mà tôi vẫn nhớ quả ấn tượng của
thầy không dục ví thầy có quả phong bì À
nó đúng là cái phong bì ấy nghĩa là cái
cái phong cái phong bì mua 500 À 200
đồng ở ngoài Tiệp tạm Hóa ấy đấy trong
đấy toàn tờ 500 ạ kiểu thầy để một cái
giấy cộp ở trong cái phong bì đấy Xong
rồi thầy còn dán măng dính lại vì kiểu
nó có bị rách nữa thầy nhét cái đấy cho
túi quần ấ xong rồi Thầy đi uống trà đá
các thứ th đúng kiểu phong cách gọi là
phong cách à ph cách khá là lập dị cách
riêng của thầy thế Thầy đi gửi xe rút
trong cái phong bì đấy t toàn tợ 500 Bun
cười vọi chưởng
không không mua biệt thự này không mua
xe ô tô vì thực ra là cái đấy
nó thầy thầy không cần thiết và nó cũng
chỉ để đánh bóng cái gì gì Hình ảnh gì
đó thầy không cần thầy có cái nét riêng
thầy rồi thế không cần phải kiểu làm mấy
cái điều đấy Và thấy là gọi nhở Cái đấy
thầy nói là cái đấy ai chẳng làm được
đấy kểu Thế ai có tiền làm được cái điều
đấy không không Mình sẽ phải có chất
riêng của mình mình không thể kiểu bị
kiể dạng làu bắt trước người khác kiểu
như thế Thấy thằng thấy ông kia giàu có
cái nhà thô mình đi kiếm cái nhà cho
kiểu nó gọi là bằng Bằng với ông đấy
không Mình gọi như mình có nhu cầu cần
điều đấy không Nếu không thì không cần
cái đấy để đánh bóng tên tuổi có nhiều
người coi cho cái đấy đánh bóng tên tuổi
giống như kiểu ông kiểu gì ông cũng phải
nên dùng con iPhone đời mới nhất này hay
là thậm chí dùng vtu này cái gì gì đó
dùng đồng hồ kiểu cao cấp gì gì đó h dù
là tôi Tôi vẫn nhớ quả đồng nghiệp Gần
đây tôi khoe quả đồng hồ gì
nh có thể chống nước được dưới 100 25 m
à 150 m gì th
đấy mấy cái đấy Thực ra là gọi nh chẳng
để làm gì codt để khoe mẽ hình ả hay gì
gì đó kiểu Ừ nó cũng sang chảnh hay gì
gì đó như tính ra thì mấy ông hiểu ý tôi
không Nãy giờ nãy giờ có có hiểu hay
thôi cứ nghe kệ nhở nhưng mà chỉ kiểu
đôi khi là mình mình cứ bị chạy theo mấy
cái đấy chạy kiểu cứ dung từ đua đòi
cũng đúng nghe là chỉ thế mình cứ cố làm
sang chảnh lên mọi thứ thể đánh bóng một
cái gì gì đó hình ảnh bên ngoài Nhưng mà
thực sự thực sự ý thì tôi Tôi không thể
nói là người giàu người ta không để ý
điều đấy không vì tôi không giàu thì tôi
không biết được nên tôi nghĩ là nếu mà
có người mà có kiểu dạng là có mắt nhìn
ấy thì đúng là họ không quan trọng điều
đấy Thật không quan trọng việc là ông
đang đi ô tô xịn như thế nào không quan
trọng ông đã có biệt thựng như nào quan
trọng việc ông đã làm những cái gì ông
bắt tay được với ai Ông đã làm việc được
với a ai đấy ông có mối quan hệ vân vân
như thế nào đúng
không đấy nên là không quan tâm việc ông
đánh bằng tên tuổi có vẻ civ của ông Ôi
nghe hoành tráng các thứ thứ hào nhoáng
các thứ C thể đúng không ạ Quan trọng
thực sự là ông đã làm được gì rồi đúng
không Ừ theo tôi như thế nên có cái chết
riêng của mình tôi nghĩ là tôi sẽ theo
kiểu như này tôi sẽ tôi thực ra là tôi
vốn đã như thế rồi nhưng mà thấy nói tôi
thêm một cái gì đó động lực giống như là
bây giờ thời điểm hiện tại sắp tối Tôi
sẽ mua mua Con xé số vì tôi thích đi xe
số tôi cũng không thích kiểu cứ cho Giả
sử tôi có ác cảm với mấy ông đi xe ga đi
Không phải mọi xe ga nhưng mà tôi khá là
ác cảm với ông là đi SH chẳng hạn đấy là
một điển hình đối với tôi đối với tôi là
như thế là một Điền hình của V kiểu là
làm màu đấy Kiểu như thế
à Hồi trước tôi cũng kỳ thị Iphone cũng
một phần kiểu thấy nó là màu ấy khi mà
ai cũng muốn xắm con iPhone mới nhất các
thứ thứ để làm màu hình ảnh như thế tôi
thì gần đây tôi có chuyển qua iPhone
nhưng là tôi dùng mua con 13 thôi và
Không Phải pro luôn COD để chỉ đủ nhu
cầu và cảm thấy là mình muốn thử trải
nghiệm
cái cái đương nhiên là cái gì à muốn thử
trải nghiệm cái điều mới thì tôi dùng là
tôi nghĩa là mình vẫn phải luôn giữ được
cái lập trường quan điểm cái chất riêng
của mình con người riêng mình đừng để bị
cái gì đó cm
dỗ Cái đấy gọi là là như nào nhỉ Tôi nhớ
là cũng có một cái từ CH nó nó là cái gì
nhỉ
tiêu dùng nhở tâm lý tiêu dùng à cái gì
mà kiểu dạng là cái tâm lý để khiến ch
Mình cảm thấy mình luôn luôn muốn mua đồ
nhiều hơn ấ
nhỉ C Hỏi cho th thì gì Cái gì
phô formal là
mà không không không phải Ý tôi là cái
gì nh Ờ cũng không phải là shop h Click
cơ nó là đúng rồi nó là chủ nghĩa tiêu
này xu hướng thói quen tiêu dùng hàng
hóa thường xuyên hơn mức cơ bản của kiểu
hơn mức cần thiết chỉ ông kiểu ông cứ
muốn mua muốn sắm hết mọi thứ các thứ
thứ để thể hiện địa vị này Cá Tính này
mà code ở thực ra để hài lòng cái tôi
của mấy ông đấy Chuẩn là cái này này đấy
rất nhiều người bị này và tôi cố né hết
sức cái này đươ nhiên là mấy ông có thể
mấy ông đang chưa bị vì mấy ông đang
chưa gọi là như nào mấy ông có thể nhỏ
tuổi hơn chưa chưa gọi là chưa đến cái
giai đoạn kiếm kiếm được nên thà mấy ông
chưa bị cái này lúc mấy ông có tiền
trong tay mấy ông sẽ bị ảnh hưởng bởi
rất nhiều cái và bao gồm có cả cái này
nghĩa là kiểu Mình muốn mua thêm nhiều
thứ mình nghĩ là nó cần không Tôi cũng
không biết là tôi giờ có đang bị dính
chưa hi vọng là chưa Nhưng tôi đã cố
chọn một cái giải pháp Khá an toàn là
tôi chọn những cái hãng tôi Tôi thích
kiểu trung thành với một vài hãng ví dụ
tôi mua quần áo thì chủ yếm một hãng
unicol chẳng hạn hoặc là mua đồ công
nghệ à đồ à đồ gia dụng đồ kiểu các thứ
thứ lin làm vặt thì tôi mua Xiaomi nghĩa
là nó kiểu rẻ bổ nhưng mà có thể không
lâu dài như mà í ra kiểu thế nó kiểu dè
dè một
tí
đấy tôi Tôi đang cố kìm lại cái này
nhiều người sẽ bị dính cái chụ nghĩa từ
dùng này nhiều code để muốn thể hiện một
cái gì gì
đó đấy Xong rồi nhiều người còn ham đấy
Kiểu s shope Hồi trước tôi đã cố né
shope vãi trưởng rồi nhưng mà có rất
nhiều đồ đúng không bán lên đấy tôi vẫn
phải dính vào mà Đúng là cảm thấy kích
thích khi mà mỗi khi mà kiểu họ giao hà
gần đến mình Mình cảm thấy cũng hay hay
Nói chung nó kích cầu kích thích kinh
khủng mà cái đấy rất nhiều dính rất
nhiều đến tâm lý học luôn
Ờ ok ui hôm nay nói tất Thực ra là thực
là chuẩn mục tiêu hôm nay của tôi mới
không biết là gì không Tôi sẽ phải nói
hết tất cả đúng này vì tôi cảm thấy là
kiểu mấy cái này để đây nó quá lâu rồi
và cứ sau một tuần tôi cảm thấy nó càng
ngày càng dài hơn nó Không ngắn đi Tôi
định nói hết thật nhưng mà đến thời điểm
này thì công nhận là nh nào
nhỉ gần 1 tiếng rưỡi rồi mà tôi nói chưa
đến một
Thôi an định về làm bên fft này tôi sẽ
không thể nói xấu được nên là cũng tôi
không phải nói tôi sẽ nói xấu nhá Nhưng
mà ý là tôi sẽ khó mà có thể nhận xét
một cách công tâm được nên là ông màt
Thực ra kể cả tôi không có về đế làm m
tôi cũng không Nghĩa là tôi nên tạo một
cái hình ảnh xấu gì đó nên là không tôi
sẽ không trả lời mấy câu liên quan việc
đánh giá bất kỳ công ty hay một cái gì
đó khác mấy ông cứ gài tôi thôi Nhìn nó
ngài
giống ông có thể để avatar học sinh Tôi
tin là ông đang lừa gài tôi
bốn tháng mà công ty xếp vô vị trí tiết
làm bác en có khí nghiệm đấy anh ừ Thực
ra Em làm tester Thực ra nó cũng chẳng
sao cả ờ em cứ ghi thật thôi miễn là em
làm công nghệ âm tin em ghi nhưng nhưng
đương nhiên là em đang Em muốn sau đó em
làm B en thì đương nhiên em không thể
ghi toàn ghi kiểu dạng hướng về tester
được thì khi mà em ghi ở công việc
tester đấy nhưng mà em vẫn nên hướng về
kiểu dạng là tư duy kiểu lập trình một
tí ví dụ là tôi đã test qua những api sử
dụng thành thạo postman kiểu sử dụng
hành hạ SQL t thứ thì nó vẫn hoàn toàn
nhảy sang lập trình được thậm chí ở Hồi
trước giả sử Giả sử Hồi trước tôi a tôi
có gợi ý cho sinh viên Tôi sinh viên tôi
nói thẳng luôn là mang tiếng là à ứng
tuyển vào vị trí Làm lập trình viên
nhưng mà nó có mỗi kinh nghiệm Hồi trước
là làm quản lý với bồi bàn thôi thôi đấy
thì nó thì nó cứ ghi
à Nó thì tôi hướng dẫn nó cách ghi ở
kiểu dạng là là mình kiểu cần mẫn Trong
một khoảng thời gian nào đó s được lên
làm quản lý này xong rồi Kiểu biết làm
việc với con người xong rồi cũng kiểu
dạng là Là biết chết trình vân vân vân
nghĩa là bài toán ở đây CV đấy Ghi tiêu
đề là em ứng tuyển vào công việc nào thì
toàn bộ kinh nghiệm Nếu có kể cả cho dù
công việc khác thì vẫn nên phải Đề cập
những cái có liên quan đến cái công việc
mà bạn muốn ứng tuyển vào đấy Nên là
viết sao cho Khéo để cho cải thứ không
liên quan mà còn Thành Liên Quan Thế là
định thế là thế không phải lươn đâu nhá
thế là thế là bạn có tư duy ở
đấy có tư duy nghĩa làm chỉ đấy ví dụ kể
cả tôi làm công việc khác nhưng tôi vẫn
có tư duy Của Một Thằng Dân công nghệ
đấy l đường mà có sao đâu chẳng vấn đề
gì cả còn hơn là bạn ghi vào là bạn thứ
nhất là không có kinh nghiệm hoặc là tận
mất tận hai ba năm kinh nghiệm nó n nào
kiểu bây giờ ra trường r tự nhiên kinh
nghiệm bạn có mỗi một năm à không phải
mỗi một năm chỉ có mỗi vài tháng ấy
người ta sẽ kiểu người ta sẽ hỏi bạn
thôi là kiểu mấy tháng trước thì em
không đi làm được đi thực tập gì à Kiểu
học trên trường ghê đế Thế à đấy các thử
thử thế lúc đấy bạn kiểu gì bạn vẫn sẽ
phải tự chia sẻ lại với họ là kiểu hồi
trước em đi làm kiểu bồi bàn hay là phá
chế gì đó Thế em không ghi vào lúc đấy
người ta còn đánh giá thấp ông hơn ông
thà Ông Ki thật lòng à là trong đấy em
có làm này nhưng mà trong thời gian đấy
em
vẫn kiểu áp dụng công nghệ không biết áp
dụng gì áp dụng chấm công à Không biết
áp dụng ví dụ là kiểu em làm hẳn cái
phần mềm kiểu cho bên đấy chẳng hạn thế
em cảm thấy là em quá quá xứng đáng với
à không phải quá phù hợp với Làm lập
trình
luôn nhưng mà đúng nếu mà giả sử mà kiểu
trong khoảng thời gian đấy mà Ông làm
đúng nghĩa là ông chỉ tập trung và làm
mỗi công việc đy kiểu bồi Bản làm mỗi
bồi bản không không nghiên cứu thêm một
cái gì đó không làm thêm một cái project
gì đó thì đúng là ông đ xem xét
tập mấy công việc kia vì không tìm được
công việc cũng như là để trang trại đếm
cuộc sống nhưng mà cũng phải thể hiện
mình có đam mê có định hướng muốn làm C
cái cái công việc này từ lâu rồi chứ
không phải đúng phát mấy tháng khi mà
Gần ra trường em mới bắt đầu quay lại
quan tâm đế đến cái này còn trước đấy
thì em không hề quan tâm thế thì nó
không được đánh giá cao đúng không
tử nó gợi ý sản phẩm cho người dùng bằng
cách nào vậy ạ Cái này Thực ra là
ồ thứ nhất là nếu mà nói không không cần
nói qua công nghệ nhá chỉ cần nói về
phân tích bài toán thôi thì phân tích
bài toán thực tế thôi đó là chỉ là
là nó sẽ phải
à nó sẽ phải thu thập thông tin các bạn
nó sẽ mua thông tin các bạn khi mà các
bạn vào trong web Nó gần như là nó luôn
biết được bạn là ai bạn đã từng lướt qua
những trong web nào bạn đã từng Tìm kiếm
những cái từ khóa nào để nó đề xuất Cái
đấy Cái cái thứ nhất thứ hai nếu mà nói
về ờ kiểu công kiểu về bên công nghệ bọn
mình đi thì nó sẽ là bản thân trong web
đấy ngoài việc lưu mấy thông ty kia nó
luôn lưu lại là nó thể lưu hơn rất là kỹ
nhá có một vài nơi là còn lưu lại kiểu
là ví dụ là những người ở cái khu vực
đấy ví dụ Giả sử nhất là quốc gia đấy nó
thường hãy mua cái gì đ nó đề xuất ra
bởi vì nó có thể từ địa chỉ IP bạn thể
biết được bạn đang ở quốc gia nào ít
nhất như thế à trước khi là bạn fake IP
hay các thứ
đấy thứ hai là những người ta mua cái
này nó sẽ thường ha mua đi kèm là những
cái nào đ khái niệm về upsale này xong
rồi
ờ ừ nó khái niệm upsale hoặc ban đồ các
thứ
thứ nó để Nói chung là đại khoi là nó
luôn phải có dữ liệu của bạn đã thì nó
mới đề xuất được h không nó còn không
thì lấy gì để đề xuất đúng không ạ Nó
thể đề xuất tất cả được nó nếu mà nó đề
xuất những cái thứ bắn chạy ấ thì nó bị
Trung chung quá nó mà hướng cá nhân hóa
được thì nó sẽ rất là
đang học
thêm has stack là gì nhỉ Ý em làm hai
nôi á học thêm Amazon cũng được cũng
được làm dep cũng tạo thêm cơ hội cho
Thực ra bằng cấp anh không đánh giá cao
lắm anh thường anh nói thế đấy rồi Ờ các
bạn khi mà đi tuyển việc mà không thể
hiện được kinh nghiệm không thể hiện
được kiểu dạng là mình phù hợp với công
việc thì cái bằng cấp của họ Bằng cấp
của các bạn cũng sẽ bị nói chung là bị
loại thôi Chỉ có một vài công ty là họ
sẽ thường ng lướt qua bằng trước rồi mới
nhìn năng lực nhưng mà gọi nh thì thưc
kh thì các bạn cũng
không tìm ở mấy công ty đấy mấy ông nên
giải CP ở
những công ty mà Thứ nhất là biết chắc
là họ cần người
Ờ công ty tôi mua ở bên nước ngoài xong
rồi ship về T không đánh giá được tôi
nhưng mà Gần đây tôi đúng là tôi có mua
m à Định mua m ở bên ma 24 gi À đấy Hôm
nay tôi mua thanh bass ở bên đấy này tôi
cũng đang cân nhắc việc có nên quả quảng
cáo bên đấy hay không hiện tại đến thời
hiện tại tôi thấy dịch vụ hay mọi thứ
rất là tốt và cũng là xếp tôi gợi ý tôi
qua đấy mua tôi mới cảm thấy uy tín mà
mua nhưng mà còn là để mà đánh giá để mà
tôi về sau tôi sẽ kiểu nói chung là như
nào nhỉ Tôi không phải tôi đi quảng cáo
cho mọi bên chẳng để làm gì cả Tôi
thường ha chia sẻ cho mấy ông rất là
thật lòng và không muốn là bị cái gì
thao túng mà đúng không bị đồng tiền hay
mọi thứ thao túng nên tôi
Ừ đấy đợ mấy cái quả bảo hành các thứ đã
xem thế nào nhưng mà đại khái Thì tôi cứ
chia sẻ thật thôi Tôi mới mua tôi không
đnh không không quảng cáo gì cả Còn nếu
về sau mà thấy ổn thì chắc là tôi cũng
sẽ chia sẻ một cách thăng thắn à Kiểu
thoải mái hơn với mấy ông là tôi tự tin
là tôi khuyên mấy ông qua đấy mua ấy
kiểu thế vẫn không ăn được Đồng Hào
quảng cáo Nhưng mà tôi thấy nói chung là
mấy ông sử dụng mấy cái khác mà tôi đã
gợi ý mà thấy ổ tự nhiên là cái uy tín
tôi tăng lên đúng
không Tôi cảm thấy là nó quay đi quay
lại vẫn là phát triển cho tôi Chứ không
phải liên quan đế mấy bên kia tôi không
quan tâm mấy bên kia vì tôi cũng chẳng
được gì từ mấy bên kia cả mấy hôm qua
đấy có nói là kiể bạn anh Long đâu mà kể
cả bạn anh Long cũng chẳng biết anh Long
nào anh Long
không Anh nhớ là cái lúc mà anh mua ở
đây cũng không phải easy lắm Bởi vì tính
ra nó hết Hàn à các thứ các thứ nhưng mà
Đúng là họ cũng sắp à họ cũng sắp xếp
được mọi thứ cho mình cũng khá là ổn Nói
chung là liên lạc mọi thứ khác tiện
thuận lợi ý nh là trước mắt như thế Tôi
thấy nhiều bên kiểu nhắn tin fanpage
kiểu kiểu mình nhắn cho nó phải hai ngày
liền rồi không được mình phải gọi nó ấy
nĩ là bên này không như
thế không phể nói là mua hạ mua lúc nào
easy đâu nhá Anh từng thấy vài nơi cho
dù chất lượng rất là tốt nhưng mà ngay
từ cái việc là kiểu đấy ngay lúc đầu ấ
ngay lúc đầu mua lúc mà mình chi nhiều
tiền nhất là nó nó còn kiểu cảm thấy hời
hợt ấy đấy chứ được nói việc là về sau
bảo hành tôi còn chưa bảo hành mấy cái
bên đấy nhưng mà Tôi thấy đánh giá không
cao lúc đấy rồi
sai Project hay Project cá nhân Ờ tôi
cảm thấy tôi là một người khá là có rất
rất nhiều ý
tưởng một phần là từ nhu cầu một phần là
nói chung Tôi để ý xung quanh thôi Kiểu
thấy Tại sao mọi người không làm này nhờ
hay vân vân vân Nói chung là tôi để ý
thôi chứ tôi cũng không tham khảo ở đâu
cả tí ra tôi không tham khảo ở đâu nhá
Đấy ông có được em đy kia của tôi thì em
thì sẽ rõ đây nó lúc nào cũng thấy tôi
có rất nhiều ý tưởng đến bây giờ vẫn
chưa làm nhưng là nhiều ý tưởng Cực
đấy Nên là nói chung là tôi sợ Thích
thích cái mấy ông inbox tôi tôi có nhiều
ý tưởng cần làm cực chia sẻ bớt cho mấy
ông mấy ông làm tôi cũng muốn làm nguồn
lực thì có hạn cay
vãi mình mình kiểu mình cần Làm Tỷ thứ
như là mình thì có nhiều việc vãi chưởng
kiểu cũng hơi lười nữa nên hành
ng đây đứa em kia của tôi là cánh tay
tôi sẽ cho cánh tay phải vì nói gì em
đấy cũng sẽ làm hỗ trợ tôi em đấy thì
lại có nhược điểm và nó là nhược điểm
nhưng mà thực ra nó phù hợp với tôi đó
em đấy cũng chẳng nghĩ là được ý tưởng
mấy nên th em ấy sẽ làm theo ý tưởng của
tôi thực ra là hai thằng mà không T được
không có việc đ
trình bày ở đây thôi còn việc up lên đấy
nó bị công nghiệp quá rồi mấy ông cứ đổ
xô vào làm thì hết sự ý tưởng tôi làm
mất
ờ Mobile app à Hồi trước tôi định làm
cái kiểu app
a thôi đế định bảo làm cái to đù thì
phải
I cái gì nhở Ui có như cái tưởng qu
không nhớ hết
inbox qua Zalo à nhầ kh
miệng đừng có inbox và Zalo nhá Ừ mấy
cũng không biết số tôi đâu đừng có cố
tra số tôi cũng được ờ inbox qua
Facebook hoặc
Zalo đ c Muốn né ra rồi Ở đây tại Xem
tiktok của mỗi bạn chẳng K sao bạn thấy
hơi tí bạn tán người khác rồi hỏi bạn có
Zalo không Tôi bị ám ảnh cái video
hướng với công việc thường là tôi tôi
dùng discord theo công việc Messenger
bây giờ đúng kiểu quá tạp nham discord
của của tôi thuần công việc mấy ông nhắn
qu discord là ổn Nhất
ờ Messenger rất nhiều lúc tôi bị trôi
tin nhắn trên đấy tạp nham quá có rất
nhiều cái tôi định kiểu sẽ kiểu không Xẽ
kiểu đã xem hoặc là đánh dấu là chưa xem
ấy để mà đợi trả lời các bạn như nó bị
trôi luôn ý nó trôi quá nhanh luôn hạn
chế nhắn nếu mà nhắn tin qua Facebook
thì nên nhắn qua một là fanpage hai là
discord là ổn nhất ông cứ tạo hẳn th ở
trên server discord ấy thì tôi thì anh
em mọi người vào xem rồi Tôi vào đấy tôi
trả lời thì mọi người cùng nhìn thấy
công khai mình cần gì phải giấu Đúng
không Mình có gì
tele tôi không ngại cho các bạn số đâu
nhưng mà nhưng mà vẫn
ngại vì 10 người thì chắc chắn là sẽ có
một người gì gì đó đúng
nãy có ông hỏi ch GT 4 thế nào á à Đắt
không á thì công ty tôi trả tôi nhớ là
nó công khai giá mà công ty tôi trả rồi
anh em dùng chung tính thoải mái không
quan tâm V giá lắm
Ờ còn
chity 4 thì tôi thấy là nó hơn ở khoản
nó tra luôn tài liệu Nói chung là cái
kiến thức của nó sát gần hơn ấy và trả
lời được đa Tôi cảm thấy là nó có gì nó
thông minh hơn chắc là thế còn nhưng mà
để về code thì đấy bạn kia bảo là là nó
copilot thì nó kiểu nó tối ưu và nó gọi
nhở nó tối ưu về code các thứ các
thứ có tích hợp
GT gpt 4 rồi thức ra này để mà so sánh
hai thằng nó không nó hơi bị buồn cười
thôi Bởi vì tính ra hai thằng bây giờ
đều đang của Microsoft đúng không ch gì
cái Open ai hình như bị mua lại Bởi
Microsoft mà đúng
không
ai Microsoft như mua lại rồi
A bị mua
lại Bởi
Microsoft đùng không mà Microsoft cũng
mua lại kit Hub rồi nên thành ra là kiểu
C l của github nó như nhau
phải mua lại mà đối tư vào thế thành ra
nó cũng nó cũng
kiểu kiểu dạng là gần như là những cái
gì ch activity có thì nó cũng sẽ được
Kiểu tích hợp vào bên trong thằng của
pilot đấy Nên là nên là tôi thấy là
không thể so sánh theo kiểu đấy bởi vì
Bở vì nó hiển nhiên ý
đấy chỉ biết được copilot chuẩn là nó
chuyên về code thì các bạn tôi vẫn hỏi
chity về code bình thường nhá Nhưng đang
nói là cái tiện í tôi cài như là cài C
pilot
nên giờ mới đi tìm việc anh đánh giá em
liệu nhiều so với
tuổi Ừ tôi quen người 35 tuổi bây giờ
còn mới bắt đầu học lợp trình nên tôi
không không bao giờ đánh giá mọi người
qua tuổi tác cả tôi dạy cho những người
35 và 40 lớp khóa bổ túc của tôi hồi
trước để mà lúc đấy mà bắt đầu học họ
hồi trước họ còn làm những cái công việc
không hề liên quan đến công nghệ thông
tin nhưng mà họ rất là cần mẫn và họ rất
là chịu khó và tôi biết có rất nhiều
không phải rất nhiều công ty tuyển thì
nó không đúng nhưng mà có rất nhiều công
ty
có có những cái lập trình viên cũng có
tuổi nhưng mà
bài toán ở đây nó là về sau mế ông sẽ
nhận ra điểu đặc biệ Bây giờ thời buổi
ai giờ còn phát triển nữa mấy ông sẽ
nhận ra một điều đó là mấy ông Làm lập
trình viên không phải là ngồi cốt nhiều
mấy ông ngồi nghĩ nhiều thì rõ ràng là
Nếu giả sử Giả sử nhá bạn 40 tuổi chăng
nữa
ờ thứ nhất là bạn học tương đối cũng
được đi không cần phải mức nhanh không
cần kiểu vẫn còn quá sáng suốt thông
minh nhưng mà bạn bạn à Làm cũng tương
đối được việc và bạn áp dụng được ai để
hỗ trợ việc bạn code các thứ các thứ có
vấn đề gì Mình không nhớ đ Mình dùng
Google CH hỏi ai bình thường mà
so với rất nhiều bạn fer kiểu mới ra
trường bây giờ mấy bạn đấy quá thiếu
ngoài việc kinh nghiệm chuyên môn còn
thiếu ở kinh nghiệm thực tế ngoài đời kỹ
năng sống của bạn ấy rất là yếu các bạn
hơn các bạn đấy ở kỹ năng sống hơn rất
nhiều để các bạn đấy làm việc được với
nhóm làm việc được với sếp đặc biệt là
bây giờ cứ nói thẳng luôn Tôi ở genz
nhưng mà Đúng là tôi vẫn chạy kiểu rất
nhiều người Thế hệ bây giờ là bị cái tôi
cao cao hơn gọi là cao thì thực ra cũng
tốt thôi nhưng mà Đấy trong trường hợp
bạn có năng lực còn đây cao ở đây là làm
chỉ là cao hơn so với năng lực của bạn
gọi là như nào nhỉ nghĩa là cái tôi nó
cao hơn cái năng lực nghĩa là
nên là thành ra là cái cách cư xử ứng xử
các bạn rất là yếu nên là các sếp thực
không đánh giá cao những cái người Kiểu
như thế cá tính thì mạnh nói thì chưa gì
bật lại mà rõ ràng có đúng đâu đúng
không Thì nó bị thì rõ ràng là chính các
bạn đấy cũng đang tự kìm hãm thế hệ các
bạn đấy nên ông nào mà bứt ra được và
ông nào mà đủ bản lĩnh để mà làm thì tôi
thấy là kiểu gì mấy ông vẫn sẽ sống được
Không sao Không sao hết Mà ngành IT này
đâu phải mỗi Làm lập trình m ông hoàn
toàn thể Ờ m ông có thể kiểu học một tí
để biết qua công nghệ mấy ông nhỉ Sang
làm ba để nói chuyện với với khách hàng
TH lúc đấy kỹ năng mềm ông quá được tận
dụng luôn đấy ông thể lên làm quản lý
quản lý mà biết một tí về công nghệ nó
rất là tốt hơn rất nhiều quản lý tôi
biết đây là không hề biết tí gì về công
nghệ đấy và kỹ năng mềm của họ cũng cũng
yếu luôn ý Chẳng qua là họ hình như học
mấy cái kiểu chứng chỉ hay là kiểu khoa
học gì đó để ra làm quản lý thực ra họ
có có trên môn đâu Nói có ai nể đâu đấy
Nói chung là đương nhiên để đi làm được
thì bạn kiểu gì bạn sẽ phải có kiến thức
nhưng mà kiến thức ở đây không cần nhất
thiết phải kiến thức đúng chuyên chuyên
ngành các bạn hoàn toàn thể kiến thức
đây là kỹ năng mềm kỹ năng
sống tôi cảm thấy là kỹ năng sống
à Ừ đấy Cái đấy là gọi là kỹ năng sống b
Đúng không nhỉ Đấy bạn hoàn toàn có thể
kiểu ra ngoài Vô Tư bây giờ bảo tôi làm
sang nhảy sang ngành khác đương nhiên
tôi sẽ mất một khoảng thời gian nên tôi
nghĩ là tôi vẫn làm được vì tôi tự tin
về khoản tư duy kiểu logic của mình
không cần áp dụng công nghệ nhá và lẫn
cả là kỹ năng mềm cũng tương đối ổn thì
tôi vẫn thể làm được công việc ở cái
ngành khác vị trí khác thì ngược lại các
bạn hoàn toàn thể nhảy sang bên công
nghệ này miễn là có cũng có một tí Tư
duy và Kỹ năng
11 ngành này thiếu mấy ông kỹ năng mềm
lắm ông vào thì đánh bật được bọn nó
tập hiện tại năm đã đã tạo tạo ra năm
website và đã được diệt qua công ty
trong 2 tháng khi em đề cập đế lương thì
họ
bảo sai
thì
lại tôi đọc Đôi khi thấy hơi lùng củng
các thứ thứ nhưng mà chắc tôi hiểu ý bạn
này đại khái là bạn đấy thực tập à Làm ở
công ty cũng làm được cái gì đó rồi
nhưng mà sau hai tháng thực tập thì ờ đề
cập lương thì công ty đang từ chối thì
à tôi quan điểm đó là là không không
quan tâm việc mình đang làm được việc
nha Mà quan tâm việc là mình đã học hỏi
được không Và cái cái cái khoảng thời
gian này mình có đang cần học hỏi không
Nếu có thì THT ra th đành chấp nhận kiểu
gần như là cứ coi như họ đang đào tạo à
đào tạo mình miễn phí đi Sau đó thì mình
nhảy thì lúc đấy mình có kinh nghiệm đ
nhảy
đúng không ạ Còn nếu mà còn nếu mà bạn
cảm thấy không học hỏi thêm việc gì mình
đã làm gọi là quá ngon quá xịn rồi mà nó
mà bên công ty vẫn chưa nhận chính thức
bạn tự nhiên thôi nghỉ thôi đúng không ạ
thì coi coi coi như
là coi coi như là kiểu thời gian học ở
đây đã hết rồi tao đi tìm nơi mới đây
không còn là nơi mình học nữa đúng không
ạ ờ
Anh làm ở F shop không Tôi đã làm gì ở F
shop đâu chả làm gì
ra bên đấy cũng trực thuộc é shop đấy
nhưng mà nhưng mà định về
gần hai tiếng rồi
vẫn cái danh sách Nó vẫn dài quá
Ờ chắc là tôi đang định là hôm nay tôi
sẽ ngồi tâm sự hết để ngày hôm sau nói
về những thứ sẽ chia sẻ Đây cũng nhiều
cực mấy ông thấy là kiểu tôi ghi cũng
nhiều vãi trưởng đây nhưng mà hôm nay về
vẫn chưa đủ chắc là tuần sa buổi sau sẽ
cổ tâm sự hết vậy Ờ để buổi sau nữa tôi
sẽ chia sẻ hết cái này trước khi bắt tay
vào kiểu dạy lại code T nhiều cái quá
Tâm sự ở đây là tôi vẫn hướng đến tôi
nói lại cái định hướng kênh nh Ừ có nên
ghi ở đây không nhỉ
Ừ đại khái thì tại sao tự nhiên cái kênh
của tôi bây giờ nó kiểu bị giải trí tấu
hài Thế không phải tự nhiên tôi kiểu
thế không phải tự nhiên tôi đặt tên là
Block
à Anh có up lại stream không có nó có
lưu lại
đấy tôi tôi không tôi không định hướng
kênh này là kênh dậy mà kênh này gần như
là Cứ cho là nó giống một cái Vlog tức
cả ám trẻ nó cũng kiểu dạng là chia sẻ
lại suy nghĩ hay là mọi thứ xảy ra trong
cuộc đời tôi Ờ để tôi chia sẻ lại rất
nhiều quan điểm và góc nhìn các thứ tôi
gặp trong đời sống dưới góc nhìn của đấy
một dân cũng là it công nghệ và cũng là
wibu rồi rất nhiều cái nữa Nhữ cái và và
tôi sẽ chia sẻ không phải mỗi quan điểm
nữa mà chia sẻ kiểu dạng là
ờ những cái thứ hay ho mà tôi kiểu biết
tiếp xúc nữa tôi thấy cái gì Kiểu hay
tôi chia sẻ mấy ông đấy nó theo hướng
kiểu như thế và tôi định hướng thì nó sẽ
là kiểu tạo ra một cái ví dụ bên discord
ấy Nó là một cộng đồng mà anh em có thể
kiểu hỗ trợ chia sẻ được cho nhau rất
nhiều
cái chứ không nhất thiết phải về liên
quan vế mỗi ngày nghề không phải liên
quan đến mỗi
thì người thích tâm sự thích nói mà tôi
phải lên đây để tôi dạy tôi kiểu bởi vì
về sau tương nhiên là tôi tôi vẫn là
nghề của tôi vẫn là Làm lập trình và dạy
học thì cái việc dạy của tôi nếu mà để
chuẩn chuẩn ra ấy à thì đáng ẽ mấy cái
kênh à Mấy cái video dạy học thì chỉ nên
chuyên là dạy đúng không đấy
thì tôi về sau tôi cũng sẽ làm một cái
nhờ bên spy kiểu để mình làm lại h một
cái chuẩn chỉ về dậy này cũng như là có
slide đầy đủ các bạn Nói chung là giáo
án đầy đủ xịn hơn
à vân vân lúc đấy tôi sẽ đăng lại mấy
cái đấy để cho mấy ông chỉ muốn lên học
có thể lên đấy học nhưng mà tôi cảm thấy
nó sẽ có nhược điểm riêng nhá nhược điểm
riêng ấy nó là thực ra là có rất nhiều
kênh như thế rồi
à rất nhiều kênh kiểu dạng là
kênh học online rồi Tôi cảm thấy là kênh
của tôi nó nó có một cách riêng như này
Nó là kiểu ngoài việc dạy ra tôi tâm sự
Cái này để mấy ông cảm thấy là Ừ anh ấy
cũng chỉ là một người bình thường một
người Kiểu kiểu cũng mu cũng thật Hà đi
là chia sẻ mọi thứ với nhau và anh em
cũng tương tác như này nữa thì khi mà
các bạn dạy học à các bạn học Xem lại
những cái buổi video này để học live ấy
tôi tôi chắc chắn tôi sẽ vẫn Tuy là tôi
có thể đăng lại những cái khóa học mới
nó bài bản chi tiết hơn nhưng tôi vẫn sẽ
giữ những cái live cũ để các bạn tự đánh
giá thôi các bạn sẽ thấy là các bạn
thích học bên nào hơn có nhiều bạn thì
thích học kiểu dạng là giả sử giống như
tôi tôi là người xem livestream game rồi
chẳng hạn đương nhiên là không không thể
trực tiếp xem tôi sẽ xem lại những cái
livestream đấy tôi thích thích những cái
livestream mà nó có bình luận like kiểu
như th này này để cảm thấy là Ừ mình
đang hòa mình với những cái ông kia mình
kiểu xem m mình cảm thấy đoạn này hay
rồi mấy ông kia bình luận gieo hò cùng
mình mình h vui bây gi tự nhiên khi mà
xem mà kiểu chẳng thấy có một cái bình
luận nào cả mình cứ xem đều đều đều ấy
nó giống như kiểu bạn học online bạn
đăng ký khóa học online ở trên một cái
trang gì đó bạn chỉ học một mình thôi
bạn cảm thấy cô đơn ý không có người
đồng hành cùng ý m không hiểu ý tôi đấy
nó sẽ có cái cái riêng riêng như thế
những cái buổi live kia thì có người tâm
sự ở nói người tương tác trực tiếp với
mấy ông ở nói rồi có những cái bình luận
các thứ các thứ thì rõ ràng mấy ông cảm
thấy là tôi cảm thấy cái thời gian đầu
lúc mà live Như thế dễ học có nhiều bạn
sơ nổi hào hứng học mà đúng không ạ mấy
ông để kỹ có thấy kiểu mấy cái live đấy
mấy ông ấy hao hứng vã trưởng kiểu cũng
tham gia làm ngồi làm đồ án cùng nhau
rồi vân vân vân đấy có thêm động lực hơn
rất
nhiều bạn kiểu có phải mọi tâm sự tôi
yêu cầu mấy ông nghe đâu và có phải mọi
tâm sự mấy ông cần nên nghe đâu nhưng mà
nhưng mà nó là nh thế nên là tôi vẫn có
vẫn sẽ cố kiểu hô mà thỉnh thoảng ngồi
sửa lại ngồi sửa lại cái video r tôi
cũng sẽ chia mục lục ra để mấy ông có
thể biết mục lục là đoạn nào tâm sự đoạn
nào dạy thì mấy ông vào xem cái phần dạy
thôi nhưng mà
cái ý tôi là cái việc live như này Dạ
học nó cái hay riêng so với việc là đăng
mấy cái video quá bài bản ví dụ là có
vài bên thì so sánh tôi dạy
à À tôi nên kiểu làm cái những cái video
cô động chuyên nghiệp giống như bên F8
chẳng hạn đấy tôi có biết rất nhiều kênh
không phải một bên F8 đâu đấy thì
thì đương nhiên là mình không thời gian
làm điều đấy thật mình không đủ chy
nghiệp làm điều đấy Thật đấy nhưng mà
mình sẽ có nét riêng của mình và tôi cảm
thấy
là tại sao mình phải làm như thế luôn nó
làm chì kiểu nếu mà nếu làm thế thì mình
một là mình bắt trước người ta hai là
thế thì tại sao sinh viên mình không
sang luôn bên đấy mà học Sao bên này làm
gì bên đấy uy tín và mọi thứ chuyên
nghiệp hơn rất nhiều đúng không ạ mình
phải có chất riêng mình
thì người ta mới kiểu mới cảm thấy kiểu
đáng để theo dõi đúng không có ch Tôi
cảm thấy là nó na ná lại quay lại nó na
ná giống như kiểu Tôi hợp kiểu tâm sự
kiểu như này tôi hợp kiểu dạy theo kiểu
là thực hành như này
nó khác với nhiều người thích học lý
thuyết nhiều ông thích học lý thuyết lắm
kiểu học chắc là kiểu quen giống như là
quen học bên Bách Khoa ấy kiểu lý thuyết
các thứ thứ thứ họ Họ thích ngấm với cái
điều đấy tôi Thì quen thích kiểu thực
hành tôi dạy thực hành nhiều lý thuyết
ít đấy có người phù hợp có người không
nói chung là nó chung mà Ai Ông nào thấy
phù hợp ông nào thích nghe thì thì vui
cho cả hai thôi còn không thì skip đến
cái đoạn đó còn nghe đúng không ạ Có sao
đâu Tôi cảm thấy là
kiểu Dạ nhở à Đấy là một cái nét riêng
của mình và mình sẽ giữ Ừ Ít ra mình
nhận ra được là Đấy nét riêng của mình
và mình có cái nét riêng mình không bị
bão hòa mình không bị kiểu rộng Giống
tất cả mọi người cá đấy mới là cái giở
đúng không
thính học thêm về PH sách bên
phic có nên không ạ Thôi không trả lời
mấy câu này u bây giờ hỏi về mấy khóa
học ở bên đơn vị
kiểu này hoặc là t nhên hỏi thật thôi
nhưng mà sợ lắm không dám chia sẻ gì cả
Nói chung là tôi khuyên mấy ông là nếu
mấy ông đang học ở bất kỳ nơi nào kênh
này của tôi không phải là khuyên mấy ông
việc bỏ học N đấy xem kênh tôi kể cả x
mấy ông thấy có vẻ hợp hợp hay gì gì đó
đi đấy có vẻ nghe Giống đa cấp hơn đấy
thì mấy ông nên học từ cả hai phía để
mấy ông sẽ có thêm nhiều góp nhìn mỗi
người tôi vẫn luôn theo dõi tất cả mọi
kênh để tôi học hỏi Mỗi bên một ít cái
tính cách con người tôi là như thế vẫn
giữ cách vẫn giữ chết riêng cho mình vẫn
giữ cái chính kiến hay mọi quan điểm
riêng của mình n mình vẫn đi tham khảo
mọi người
khác bởi vì họ tôi quan điểm là họ tồn
tại hay là tất cả mọi thứ tồn tại đều có
lý do của nó đúng không ạ Họ tồn họ Tại
sao tự nhiên họ biết được có rất nhiều
cái kênh khác rồi nó họ vẫn tạo ra kênh
này nế phải có lý do của họ họ sẽ có
chất riêng của họ mình biết đâu mình
tham khảo được biết đâu nhỡ đâu kênh đấy
về sau còn nổi hơn kênh đã có trước đấy
đúng không ạ vs code Á Anh định cài thật
đấy anh anh đang chuẩn bị định cài Nếu
giả sử là khi p Storm hết hạn mà không
ra hạn được đấy sẽ cài nhưng là đừng bảo
anh dùng piton
no không có lý do gì Dùng cái đấy
Ờ nhưng đại khái thì Uầy tâm sự gần hai
tiếng rồi Mấy ông không còn hỏi thêm gì
tôi sẽ tạm nghỉ nhá tôi đi ăn tối phát
đã hôm nay kiểu hôm nay tính là một ngày
làm việc rất là hiệu quả của tối thôi
xong rồi tôi cũng tranh thu ngủ được một
tí rồi Bây giờ tôi sẽ đi ăn Tôi nghỉ
ngơi mai còn cây
tiếp
ờ không Tâm Xị gì nữa đúng không
Ok chào mấy ông
nha Chúc mừng năm mới à Không biết nh
chúc mừng trái đất xay một
vòng à đâu trời đất xoay một vòng mà
xoay một ngày ấ nhỉ đúng không
chúc mừng trái đất đã X một vòng quanh
mặt trời